Film Courage: Tony, we have a quote from you
and it is “Writing is about putting life on
the page it's about finding the amazing and
the mediocrity and the beautiful in the sewers
it's important to get it on the page and
be a writer.” Can we talk about that quote?
Tony DuShane, Writer/Podcaster/Teacher: Sure, that
sounds great. I don't know when I said that? Okay
it sounds good, yeah sure I guess probably at the
time when I was when I said that I was probably
thinking of just getting life's messiness and the
beauty on on the page or on the screen if we can
because I mean that's what I try to go that's what
I try to go for when I'm writing is what's the
heartache and then what devastates me and then
I'm like Okay now what's the levity what's the
where where can where can I find the the emotional
breath in it where because just as I continue to
write and live I just find out oh wait everything
is kind of suffering and struggle but there's
a lot of joy in it and if I'm struggling then
there's joy so let's it's I guess for putting it
on the page we condense it into a tincture of our
struggles and our Joys because when it's whether
we're writing a novel or a screenplay the it's so
much more boring than our real life our real life
is very boring and the screenplay is a condensed
version of it so if we can just condense those
the Beauty and the awfulness of just being a human
and then just kind of move it around and a lovely
tragedy sad comedy way I think that's maybe
that's what I was trying to get at I'm not sure
when you work with your students do you notice
they tend to lean one side or the other in terms
of some are more about the mediocrity and the
messiness and the others are more about the
beauty and you have to find a middle ground they
most students have a hard time just getting into
conflict I'm always more more so it's especially
beginning students or students in the second
quarter where it's like they're like this is cool
but where's this conflict and open and and it's
about finding when the writing dialogue and I and
I I see what they're doing with their characters
I'm like oh this is sexy I'm noticing something
about this character's relationship to the mother
what do you do the three-dimensional character of
the mother that she's referring to because if that
then you'll know more about that character and you
don't need to say all of it but you need to know
it and that will inform your your dialogue it'll
inform how your character presents themselves in
the room it'll inform how the character interacts
with other characters so so a lot of it is yeah
push more conflict and at the same time just
right when you just write and and get and you
get the first you get the first layer down then
you then it's funny to start noticing things
where you're just like oh wait a second that
character might have a a stepbrother who does
blank and you don't even need to add that
to the screenplay or to the story but having
that little bit of backstory brings in another
dimension of the character and it's sometimes
when it gets to a director when he gets to an
actor they're feeling something deeper because
you put something deeper in there so they can dig
into something deeper and I feel like that's when
the beauty happens and we don't tell each other
What the deeper was we let everyone do their own
deeper and then then they then yeah that's where
so my student yeah as students as students grow I
think a lot of it is just putting the time into
writing and the rewriting and put and just and
then they kind of start seeing the character laid
out and then when the characters laid out oh wait
a second it's funny how I put that dialogue in I
didn't even notice at the time but they may have
a problem with blank and explore that blank and
then come back and go does this work in here no
but I know that this person has a problem with
that and kind of layer it in later in the story
interesting so let's suppose I'm going to write
something about a CEO and this CEO is very sort
of he has almost like a dictatorship relationship
with his employees but what we don't know is his
father used to to run the company but we don't
know that as as the viewer as the reader and his
father was even more of sort of a he had like a
general that ruled with an iron fist so if we knew
that as a writer but we don't have to tell people
it's kind of in our back pocket then then it might
help with how our main character interacts we
know that he has this history with his father
yeah and we can we can put subtle bread crumbs in
there to write it that way and when it gets to a
director they may see it these I I've noticed that
they'll add their relationships and their past to
the stories so it might not even be a father it
could be an old boss they used to work with and
then so they put a dynamic to that and then when
it gets to the actor the actors like okay how am
I interpreting this on my own what what does this
mean to me and so they'll see how this character
is acting if they're acting like like they're
a dictator they'll also know that in their mind
that that that character believes that they're
doing the best they can for Humanity it's like
they're the hero of Their Own Story even if
they're awful people but so it's like finding
that balance of where is the humanity because
that humanity is coming from somewhere so it
could come from abuse of a father it could come
from so many different other things it could come
from where they grew up how they grew up and they
feel like what they're doing is right to bring in
the whole to bring in whatever group they're
trying to bring in and that's when that's when
the beauty happens and that's when we don't see
we we know it as screenwriters but then we don't
say it and then it's fun to see a director go oh
and then they just kind of see them start to bring
their own stuff in they see the actor bring their
own stuff in and just don't ask any questions just
let them do their thing that's that's when the
Great directors and the great actors are just
like they pull it together so we got to do
our part on the page and then that it makes
it it's it gives them a huge opening to explore in
themselves whatever part of the camera they're on
interesting right so so having so knowing when
to get out of the way of your own work and allow
the the actor and the directors to kind of bring
their own pieces to it oh totally yeah and and
especially for for Confessions of a Teenage Jesus
Jerk I was a part of the whole process when I was
on set every day and and I just I was fortunate
I've taken acting classes and I took classes on
directing like 20 years ago and then when and
then when all when all that came together it's
like everything came together of oh okay I kind
of knew what to do and what not to do when I got
on set and it was just like let it breathe and
then when when I felt like there needed to be an
adjustment I would never talk to an actor I would
talk to the I would just pull the director aside
really quick and go hey and it had to be a it had
to be a major thing and I would just like oh this
this and this and they'd be like okay you turn
around he goes what let's try something else and
he would be taking my note but it wouldn't be it's
there's a beauty in finesse I guess to to letting
people do their jobs and you want to let people
do their jobs because they are good at their jobs
so with your students when it's a new writer and
and you you want to bring out more in them maybe
maybe they're afraid of putting in Conflict
maybe they've been told oh let's only say nice
things we don't want to we don't want to be a bad
person or whatever how do you how do you coax them
to not not do something overly salacious where
anyone's harmed but let's bring some realism to it
I think that I think the conflict's already
there sometimes I call it the agreeables
so if there's a if they send me two
pages of a scene and it's agreeable
that those characters can't agree with the outcome
but they can't agree to what the outcome is how to
get to the outcome so they they their point of
view needs to be very needs to be almost like
what would you say maniacal because their point of
view is right on the page to get to that outcome
and they both want to get to the same outcome but
to get there there's got to be friction amongst
themselves so if they're agreeable Then I then
that's when I'm just like what's your character's
point of view on this exactly why do they want to
get there what's behind theirs okay what's behind
them what if they're sisters What conflict do
they have with being siblings if they're just
best friends What conflict do they have if they're
cops in a buddy movie great they're buddies but
these buddies are going to be at odds with each
other on how to get to where they both want to go
how do you search for those beautiful moments in
the midst of tragedy I think I find the tragedy
first I think that tragedy is what guts me
and then and then I try to find meaning in
the tragedy meaning and my tragedies and it's
hard to find meaning in the tragedy I've I've
I mean since Confessions of a Teenage Confessions
of a Teenage Jesus Jerk I've written two other
books where I went even deeper into tragedies and
one I checked myself into a outpatient hospital
program because I was suicidal so the I've had
to learn to pick my tragedies and then also
and also give them time I think and that's
I wasn't giving my tragedies enough time but
I the the beauty of tragedy is we're we all have
tragedies we all it's we connect on it and I think
I think as humans we we connect more on not just
the tragedy but how we got out of the tragedy like
even in film even in film it's like you put your
character into conflict then we want to know how
are they going to get out of the conflict how are
they getting out of that little tragedy moment
in scene and then that's what shows character
building and I feel like we're character building
around each other when we do have tragedies
in our lives when we can we find our ways to
pull out of it and then survive and then go wait a
second okay how does this work for me in in being
with other people and then other people it's it's
just the beauty of oh yeah I've been through that
you just you hear someone who goes oh yeah now
I've been through that I get it that's all you
need and you're like ah and there's just instant
camaraderie with tragedy which is sad I don't
know why we need tragedy and we all just can't be
joyful Buddhas but for some odd reason tragedy and
suffering I think is in the theme of our lives
and our existence so when we put it on the page
and we get to see our protagonist get into
the tragedy get into the conflict whatever the
conflict is the conflict could be the protagonist
wants to ask the woman of his dreams out on
a date or it could be the protagonist is being
riddled by bullets and they're trying to die when
they're in the trenches and as far as the film is
concerned and the conflict's concerned the stakes
are the same and as far as what the characters
internal tragedy is happening I like to even
even when I have students who are writing romantic
comedies and they apologize for it I'm sorry I'm
like don't apologize and I was like watch mob
movies watch mob movies and and as you look at
the Beats of the conflict of the mob movies it's
very simple because there's a lot of hierarchy
involved and then bring it over to your romantic
comedy and you can add those beats in and keep
those Stakes just as high as the mob film and but
it's but it'll be under the guise of a romantic
comedy and the greatest the the fun comedy Vibe a
lot of it comes from a tragedy or a tragic place
and that's when it's even more funny yeah so
that's great do you have certain movies you
recommend one romantic comedy versus one mob
movie oh that would be yeah I wish I had those
I while I watched that TV series Gamora
recently the Italian I think is the Italian one
but as for mob movies I'll tell them to
watch I mean I I spoke ahead I don't have
I'm not a I don't have a good I don't have a good
knowledge of romantic comedies or mob movies but
one one movie I bring up a lot in class
and it drives some people nuts is swingers
I think that was 1996. John
Favreau and Vince Vaughn and
their group of friends and John favreau's
character his name's Mike and he's the protagonist
and he's trying to get over his girlfriend that
he's trying to get over heartbreak he's trying to
make it in LA but mainly he's trying to get over
heartbreak and everyone in the movie just wants
to help him get over heartbreak but if you really
watch the movie and you watch the dialogue that's
happening they are fighting the whole time it's
almost like they're about to come to blows with
their dialogue but they all want the same thing
they just want Mikey to feel better Mikey just
get over your girl your ex-girlfriend but they're
they're it's a constant push and pull and it's
funny and it's sad and so when this when their
BR when the point of view of each character is
bringing in that high of stakes to the same goal
that's when it's I mean if it's a it's a tragedy
to watch the movie the whole movie's a tragedy
but it's hilarious because everyone's the the
angle they're fighting at is just funny sure
sure I didn't think there are some in Moonlight
and Mystic Pizza there's a lot of dialogue that's
very similar to that too where there's it might
be loving but they're yelling and and sort of it
is like rapid fire with the dialogue yeah that's
and that's when it's beautiful and that's when
we connect because it's like we want we want the
character to win it's like how is the character
going to win how are they going to get there and
then we almost when when they're when there's
heavy conflict on the screen it's almost like
they start to go into a situation like no don't
go there okay if you go there you better do blank
blank and blank and of course they're not going
to do that because we want to keep the movie
going another five minutes so it can't be resolved
yet they need to get more sand in their eyeballs
before they get to the next scene so why do you
think your student s feel they have to apologize
or some of them feel they have to apologize for
wanting to write romantic comedies I don't know
it's I think people apologize for genre sometimes
and and I'm just like don't apologize it's
every story means something no matter what you're
doing and it's and it's what you love just it was
write the movies that write a movie that you
love that is why do we go to see movies and
you and whereas movie Just Hits you in the heart
and you're like oh my God that movie is great even
if it's Pretty Woman but if that's what gets
you if that's what stirs your soul there's a
reason for it write that right don't write that
movie but write write the write the general idea
and the general theme of that movie right write
the Meg Ryan Tom Hanks movie it's all just it's
I think maybe there's a there's a pressure for
like oh is it Oscar worthy oh with this with
this would Meryl Streep be cast in this and it's
just like no right right your truth right what's
important to you and that's going to make the
best movie that you can make no never write
towards something that you just feel like is a
good idea that's that everyone's on and on about
remember the movie Foxes I don't oh okay it has
Scott Baio Jody Foster, Sally Kellerman and is
from The Runaways Cherie Currie oh my god oh okay
so and it's a and it's the one of these movies
where it just doesn't leave you and so it's one
of these things where you would say it and people
go oh you like that movie but there shouldn't
be anything wrong with liking a movie Yes it
calls to you I totally agree and I don't like
it when people dirt on other people for liking
something right that just irks me to no end and
I think that doesn't lead to more conversation
that leads to a stop and so I just if it doesn't
matter what people like it's fun it's it's like
when I come from the music a College radio music
DJ which was the snottiest the snottiest in the
1990s and I was that jerk and I could so and
it started to realize wait just because someone
doesn't know Sonic Youth or the Acoustics
doesn't mean that they're inferior humans
or maybe they don't like a certain thing like
even the it's if they don't like something it's
fun to find out why that's the that's the oh why
don't you like that or why do you like that well
I found a I found a Backstreet Boys song for a
project I was working on and I'm like this is
perfect and I I know everyone's there's gonna
be a lot of people that are going why is Tony
putting a Backstreet Boys song in there but but
it's just like it's just perfect and if someone
wants to go see the Backstreet Boys just let them
let them enjoy their experience I don't like it
when people try to crush people's experiences
if they want to see Meg Ryan and Tom Hanks
possibly get together great why why do you like
that movie that's that's we should be passionate
about it because every life's hard enough as it
is so taking a crap on people's taste is kind of
the last thing we need to do let's try to find out
why they like a certain thing that's where the fun
stories are as far as I'm concerned yeah I agree I
agree I think people should whether it's music or
books or or film yeah you should be entitled to
if we want to watch a real cheesy movie and and
enjoy it and and or even have it playing in the
background all the time there's something that
calls to us I use Ocean's 11 a lot in my this is
the Soderbergh I always say his name wrong I hope
I said it right that time his his remake but that
movie's gorgeous as far as a heist movie and all
the elements of Storytelling and I actually I'll
watch it for fun sometimes and people kind of are
just like it's like oh yeah well that top 40 movie
what are you talking about and I'm like no there's
actually there's a lot of great scenes in there
that I'll bring to class and show the Dynamics of
and just the dialogue and the dialogue is tight
and those actors are all top-notch actors yeah
some of them are superstars that's fine but they
are great at what they do and there's a reason why
most of them are superstars it's because
they've worked really hard to get there
how do you write evil easily enough unfortunately
I think we got a lot of evil in all of us so it's
okay to just dive into the part of us that's
dark if I'm it's I think writing evil is
to write evil you have to almost pretend like no
one's going to read it because you don't want you
don't want to anyone to think you're evil oh my
God I would never be that evil well there's just a
beauty to knowing we all have an evil inside of us
and we can go there we just choose not to sure so
there's there's just a beauty of just
really letting it go on the page and not
and and some people will read it and be like
oh I mean I I can't write serial killers like
that narrative just that scares me I don't like I
can never watch a serial killer film those things
just don't make sense to me but we we can find we
can embrace the our Tendencies because because we
all have bad in us it's and we're not we're not
politicians well politicians have more bad than
people than normal but but we're not trying
I don't think we need to present ourselves
as beautiful flowers where we we're all a little
corrupt and especially in the film industry you
see a lot more corruption under the guise of
like oh this is virtue and you get behind the
curtain a little bit and you're like ooh so it's
kind of easy to write evil it's almost easier to
write evil than it is to write Evil's interesting
it is yeah and do you think it's more interesting
to write a virtuous character who secretly
has evil or an evil character that you see
it and you go okay this is definitely evil and
then you're seeing sort of what that person's
life is like Are we more intrigued by what's not
shown and what we're discovering as the audience
as well I'll first answer that as the writer so
what I try to do is when I find I go back into
my life and I go what I hate that I hate that
person I hate what they did to me I'm gonna
write a character about them and I'm gonna show
everybody just what a piece of crap human being
this person is and when this person watches the
movie they're gonna go oh my God that's me I need
to change my life so that's the original intent
and then I start working on the character and I
start massaging the character and then I start to
realize oh crap I have empathy for the character
and then I develop more and more empathy and
I'm like oh crap that character is part of me
the character may never really grow in the story
may still be a piece of crap in the story but I
develop empathy for why they're not good people
but as far as the layers of an evil person having
virtue and a virtuous person having evil I think
it's I want to tackle both of those both of those
intrigue me to no end because there is a flip side
to everything there's so it's and I don't think
I would actually The Virtuous person who has
who's not getting in touch with the evil would
intrigue me more than working with on an evil
person that has virtue because because there's
the the with with a virtuous person they're
they're actively pushing down that evil where
with with an evil person they're actively going
I'm virtuous no really I'm virtuous can you think
of any characters that bring to mind that are evil
that you actually have empathy for I know a lot
of people have talked about the Joker but that
you go what maybe this person there's you have
some soft spot for that person yeah well the evil
characters I mean for the most part the antagonist
if it's a like a like a superhero movie or
a James Bond or a mission impossible the the
antagonist has to be more interesting
than the hero I think that the layers
got to be there and then then we're like
how is the hero going to get through this
so I find the K do I have empathy for the for
the hero for the antagonist and those kind of
hero type movies I think I just get a kick out of
how evil they are and I'm like happy they're evil
because I'm sitting there enjoying their evilness
and how how is Tom Cruise going to get through
blank blank blank in the in those in those total
formula movies that I just adore beyond belief I
know they're not going to die at the end that's
not the question the question is how are they
not going to die that's what that's what keeps us
watching why is evil important and storytelling I
think we're intrigued with eagle evil I think if
we I mean I grew up in a very religious household
so there's the Bible the Bible is just all evil
this is bad this is bad this is bad don't do this
and there's there's a lot of and then they
go through this there's so many evil stories
in the Old Testament you're like wait God's
telling you to kill your own son there's there's
I think our Collective mythology has just a ton
of evil in it and we may try to paint it as like
oh no no we're all good we're all good but you
think about how we got here and what's going
on and evil is the theme Genghis Khan man that
guy's a hero of his narrative but what did he do
actually I can't remember what did he do
he pillaged he pillaged and it's like the
Norwegians the Vikings what did they do they were
they're Heroes of their own stories but they're
decimating cultures so I think I think it's a
general Narrative of what what we should explore
and that's and then how and then how are we
coping with the evil around us and then how
are we coping how are we coping with empathizing
with evil things and there's times when there's
beautiful times and I have evil thoughts even
if I'm just driving around Los Angeles and I'm
like that person who cut me off probably shouldn't
exist on this Earth there's a little joy to having
that fantasy even though we don't act out the
fantasy but we do get to write down the fantasy so
I think I don't think we don't go through the
whole day with all virtuous thoughts I was I
was just at Starbucks getting a cup of coffee
and this idiot in front of me is like had this
huge two different credit cards all these all
these stipulations to his order all he got was
one drink and one thing I thought he was an Uber
Eats guy and this guy's just and I'm going and I'm
sitting there going that guy might be it's part
of the human Collective he may be dispensable
and then it's just it's a fun thought to think
about but in real life we never do it and then
if I followed him home I would see that he's not
a good father to his kids and he was just having
a rough day so that's there's where there's evil
and there's empathy we need we need the whole we
I guess we need the whole story and that's why we
tell the story we need the whole story to map out
the the whys of he was the antagonist in my life
for five minutes because my venti coffee was late
okay no I talk about going way out no I saw
someone at a store the other day trying to return
something but quote didn't have the credit card
and was arguing and the workers were very nice and
they said I'm really sorry sir if you come back
with the credit card you'll be fine no no I need
service and and wouldn't take no for an answer and
in that moment I'm looking at the person like okay
this is weird and doesn't seem right but who knows
maybe legitimately it didn't have the credit card
and it just you had the receipt or they shouldn't
be on this Earth anymore they had all this stuff
but my point is I mean we we see we used to see
tabloids and we would see evil there and now we
can go on social media and now we're all judges
of what's evil even if it's one video of somebody
pushing someone in a convenience store yeah and we
don't know what happened on the other end to prom
we don't know we just see that one snippet and
so now we're watching evil played out in in real
life quote unquote but we don't know who really
was the offending party who was the first one
to sort of prompt something so and that's just
that's that's really intriguing because that's
all point of view so we're getting we're getting
everyone tells their own truth and I'd rather have
I'd rather have that in fiction and on the page
and be able to work it than to try to understand
the real social media conflicts that we get that's
where I'm just like I'm skeptical of all of them
looking for writers to go to Dark Places I
used to think that it was important to live
I one of my favorite writers is William
T. Vollmann and he's a guy that would go
to the would stay in the tenderloin and
stay at a house to and and do crack and
he and he's actively said these
things so I even interviewed him it's
published but he would actively go to these
places and and I thought what I need to do what
he does not not to the crack end but I needed
I want needed to be around certain elements
that were dark in order to get inspiration
and I've I realized I don't I really don't
it's there's dark everywhere we don't need to
seek it out there's there's dark amongst us
and it's and maybe that's why Vollmann's
written so many more great books than I've
ever written maybe maybe maybe I'm doing it
wrong and he's doing it right when he goes
I mean she's he embeds himself in
war and does a lot of he's he's
what he does is gets there and feels it and
needs to know the whole story but that's what
he's writing I'm not writing that and I don't need
to I don't need to essentially try to lose my mind
if I'm working on a character that's trying to
lose their mod that that's losing their mind and
then go wait a second I need therapy three times
a week now it's just I think what I need to do
is to and what all writers need to do is just
go what's my personality who am I don't need
to try to be someone else I would love to be a
Vollmann but I'm not a Vollmann so it's within
my parameters and my daily life the dark doesn't
the dark comes to us no matter what I don't it's
anyone who seems as privileged and wealthy and
thinking it seems like they have it all together
no there's dark there they don't need to go
move into a dark area they they have a wealth of
they have a wealth of material that they
can build from from their own experience and
a sort of Gonzo journalism Hunter S Thompson
approach you don't have to necessarily take
that but what about recounting dark stories do you
find sometimes with your students that they have a
tough time or there's others that they can't turn
it off that it's like flows like a a bad faucet
well the the problem with the true stories that
come in with my students is they say oh no this
really happened and this is true and I'm like but
it's not interesting enough you're not you're not
putting enough conflict in there so it's usually
this happened and this made me really upset and
I'm like okay yeah but make me care so you can it
could be based on something true but to make that
particular event that was true to you and dark to
you to make it Universal you're going to have to
really kind of dissect it you're going to have to
move maneuver it around you're going to have to
play with it and massage it to get the essence
of what happened we need the emotional essence
of what happened we don't need the play-by-play so
when it comes to true things that happen I think a
lot of the times when I'm dealing with students is
get out of the play-by-play what's the what's the
what's the emotional effect that you're trying to
get through because that's more there's more truth
to conveying the emotion than just
showing the play-by-play because
we want to get to the hearts of
our of our readers and audience
do you think that sometimes we think a story is
interesting and it's not it's not really that
well or that any any story can be interesting
even if it's just someone waiting in line for
coffee and there's a person who's paying with
two credit cards and needing special attention
um yeah it's I think I think every story
is interesting but it has that's when the
idea that's when the idea comes up this
idea sounds good but it has to be put
on the page the the idea that's not put
on the page is not a fleshed out idea so
there who wrote that book it was the whole book is
the timeline of the book is a guy on an escalator
going down or up the escalator I think it's
called mezzanine and I can't remember the
author's name right now and that sounds like
a very boring book if you were to pitch that
oh yeah this whole book is based on a
guy going down an escalator in a mall
that's like well that doesn't sound interesting
put it on the page though craft it and it becomes
something that people are engaged with so I think
we can knock out our we I find joy in in the most
mundane things and then I'll write them down and
then as I keep writing them and massaging them
then I'll be like oh wait there is something
in there there's something in the mundane
oh that's cool but it ha I mean it has to be
written for for anything to happen that's so
if I were to write that story about the guy
at Starbucks probably most the story would
be based on what a terrible eye what person
I am but from but not I that's how I would
approach it but I wouldn't approach it from that
point of view I would approach it as the hero of
the story but it would be dissecting everything
that's terrible about my thought process while
as I'm writing the protagonist that's me that
protagonist is not going to know that their
thought process is terrible and then that's
where comedy will probably come in because
the the or the urge to do all these certain
things I'll look back at it and I'll be like
that's when I find the empathy in other people
and I know and I realize the stupidity of myself
and the stupidity is glorious and he's just like
this is pretty presumptu this presumptuous who
am I to judge and it's just like that's that's I
think that's the juice that's a lot of fun for me
what is plot great question plot is conflict
so well we need the character first I for me
I always need the character first sometimes
though I do come up with a with a situation first
and plot's kind of a situation but we do have to
put the character in the situation so we put a
character in a situation and the character has a
goal and great the character has a goal and then
the character moves forward to that goal and we
throw obstacles at that character and that's plot
how is the character going to move through those
obstacles will they will they make the right or
wrong decision will they learn from that decision
that's essential a plot is to me is throwing
obstacles at the character and then seeing how
they get out of them For Better or For Worse
and then how they move on to the next scene so
that's when that's that's that's when the beauty
of creating the plot and essentially creating
the three-act structure that kind of turns into
this huge showdown at the end but we need to know
how the character gets in and out of obstacles
throughout the whole movie and then that's when
that's that's adding to the plot it's all pointing
to One Direction when we get to that when we get
to that Showdown so how would you teach plot
right now if I'm a new student and in class and
like a sort of a Reader's Digest version of
I like to come up with I like to come up with
really lame like like the lamest situation
like I'll say so let's say your character
wants a wants to buy gum okay great that's any
because any any goal as long as the characters
totally invested in the goal makes sense so the
character Wants to Rule all of the world great if
the character wants to stick a gum great but but
it needs to mean just as much to that character to
get that stick of gum so let's get them a stick
of gum great the stores across the street now
as your character walks walks to get that stick of
gum what can you do to make it harder for them to
get that stick of gum and then I throw it to my
students and it's just like let's just be absurd
let's be totally absurd what would you do I get
a baseball bat and I knock him in the knees great
knock them in the knees beat those beat those
kneecaps out but that character still needs that
gum and we're gonna love that character for using
his elbows to try to get to that store to get to
the gum what can we do next and so we can create
a we're creating plot by just throwing essentially
rocks at this character who wants something so bad
and it's so the that's where there's a lot of fun
I have a lot of fun discussing plot with my
students because it's just like let's come up with
the silliest scenarios and then great now when you
go to your scene where the woman wants the wants
the man to ask her on a date but she's not sure
what he thinks of him the the stakes are just as
high as if someone wants a piece of gum or someone
wants to be the ruler of the world now what are
the obstacles you're going to put in and then
when they have a character worksheet they know
the flaws and the strengths of their characters
then they know how to like bring all of that in
heighten it beyond belief and then we we're gonna
watch that scene and be like is he gonna ask her
out or not so that's essentially a plot to me
okay and then should I be writing this like
sidebar thing that no one's going to see that I'm
going to know about the convenience store clerk
and that's going to help set up the maybe
the tension in the scene so our protagonist
is going to run in and they're going to Fumble
for change for this gum and there's going to be
something about this clerk that's going to
now add new conflict maybe that clerk used
to be a CEO and they were let go and and and
this is a job they got and they remember this
person because that was one of their employees
and now I mean so but but necessarily the or
the the audience will know that I have all this
backstory but there's going to be a tension there
yeah and as long as I feel like as long as the
story stays on the protagonist who wants the gum
and then this is another this is another obstacle
so they actually make it to the store after all
of my all of my students have thrown in all their
we're gonna take out his tongue and his teeth he
won't be able to chew gum okay what are we gonna
do there and then yeah you add even more tension
when we get to the store we can have we can have
another antagonist of sorts blocking the actual
getting of the gum or or that that maybe we maybe
the protagonists get to help or maybe the clerk is
a helper in the situation and then we and because
our our heroes do need helpers along the way and
then but then we'll lose that helper but it's and
that's when we have the victories and the losses
if we give too much losses if we're throwing
too much loss at a character then then we'll
lose our audience but we get that character that
Victory it's like oh the gum great what's next
that's what we need we need to ask the question
what's next and we also need to give them we need
to give them a moment to breathe and go ah we
got the gum and then I don't know where to go
from there and because that's such a simplistic
story but that's yeah that's the victories and
losses and when I work with my students when they
do their beat sheets I try to I'm like no where
the victories are nowhere know where your breaths
are because you need to give your character oh all
right I got this and but that's the last thing
they got because the next thing's coming up and
gonna hit them even harder it's like fix that
and then boom next so so do you find a lot of
writers maybe they're more intermediate they're
they're not letting it breathe enough they know
hey I need conflict and I need to buy this point
but now they're they're infusing too much conflict
I it's I think it's better to have more conflict
than less because it's it's a lot of fun to throw
the conflict in there and then pull it out and go
that's too much that's too much where yeah and and
sometimes people ask it feels so manufactured and
I'm like it is manufactured it feels fake it is
fake it's just like it this isn't this isn't real
life this go ahead and feel awkward about it not
feeling real because you just keep crafting it and
crafting it and in the world of in the building
of the world of and this is one people talk about
World building and science fiction movies or other
things there's World building romantic comedies
there's World building in every single movie so
Build That World stay in the confines of the
world and then yeah and let them run let the
let the characters run right because if you
want to go to Mystic Pizza or Pretty Woman or
whatever that mean mean there was World building
and all that you have a small New England town
this restaurant you got is it Conchita Farrell
she was like she ran the restaurant and it's kind
of a fun atmosphere but it's no nonsense and and
they're waiting for this food critic to come in
that they're all terrified of that's gonna either
make or break the restaurant so they're getting
ready before the shift they're polishing whatever
and so now we feel like okay I'm in this small
town I know that this restaurant means everything
to this owner and and there when the food critic
comes in they're all smiles and it's probably
overly they're giving too much attention yeah so
not even sure where I'm going with that I think
I just well I explained all of Mystic Pizza
sorry right and I still need to watch the film
actually I feel bad please I need to watch it but
but you said you you said exactly the thing it's
the it's everything they want it's their whole
their character we don't need to know that they
have these other wants in their lives are they
sexually satisfied in this relationship that
we're not seeing off screen who cares we need
to know that that restaurant critic coming
in is the most important piece of their life
sure sure and there might be a little
bit of that in Mystic Pizza too yeah
what do you say to writers who tell you that plot
doesn't matter there are writers who
say plot doesn't matter there might be
um I think well I was the what you asked me like
think of some movies that meant everything to you
in one of our email exchanges and I was thinking
of Stranger Than Paradise the Jim Jarmusch film
and and the reason that meant to everything to
me is because I saw it when I was a kid on the
PBS affiliate in San Francisco channel nine yes
for some odd reason they why they showed it over
and over again they said this is only 67 takes
and blah blah blah but it made me realize that a
movie is a craft and not just that's when I kind
of that's when I got the separation went oh wow
and like a movie like that seems plotless and a
lot of it is plotless to an extent or is it I'm
I'm am I thinking of the one where they have they
open with the two Elvis enthusiasts on a train the
gym German that's mystery trained oh okay because
I love that one too and then they go in this hotel
and okay all right no that's a lot more that is a
lot more plot this is the one with John Lurie and
where they're just his Hungarian cousin comes
to stay with him in Brooklyn and it's yeah it's
like there's plot in there so I it's I like what
what film wouldn't have what can you think of a
film that doesn't have plot okay I know I'm not
supposed to use this reference Dinner with Andre
My Dinner with Andre does that have plot I haven't
seen it you haven't seen it okay well there
yeah I can't use that reference anymore but I
think they're but I think I know the I know the
actors in it and I remember seeing clips of
it they do want something that's true and if
they want something do they get it are they are
they are they having a conversation where they
where they shift the where they where they
shift the idea in the other person's mind
where the other person has a oh I
didn't think of it that way a moment
or are they just kind of coming at each other
with this is me this is me this is me this is me
so yeah well that's why I haven't seen my Dinner
with Andre because there's no plot why would I
watch that no apparently it did very well but but
I'm just thinking that I'm just thinking of that
from from a long time ago but yeah it's I mean and
that's just it's hard to come up with an example
of a movie that doesn't really have plot even
if it's I love I love slow Scandinavian films
I love I mean there's this author T singer that
I read his books and they're about nothing and
it just it brings me absolute joy and the plot
is like a little bit there's even there's even
YouTube channels that show Norwegian trains just
going from Oslo to Bergen and I'll watch it and
so it's it might be there's no plot there but
there is forward momentum there's no obstacles
but there's forward momentum so maybe that's maybe
that's the an example of a reason not to have plot
I where yeah I'll watch something but I think I
watch it more for artistic reasons than I do for
like oh my God I can't wait till they I can't wait
till they get to Stavanger it's no I barely care
so it I think I think I don't care but I enjoy
that makes sense yeah there's great Norwegian
or Scandinavian in general YouTube channels where
they talk about different Christmas customs and
things like that and they are really fascinating
to watch how they put it together yeah it's very
artistic no I could watch Dolphins just go in and
out of the water for two hours and I'll be in the
march of the Penguins I mean What a Beautiful
film there I if I remember right there is plot
to it because they are going somewhere to I
think it's all about the reproduction and the
likes they have to take so there are very high
stakes in the march of the Penguins and it's
presented to us in a kind of a light-hearted way
but but there's still Stakes there yeah I think
I would not be interested in filmmakers who
don't who think that there's no reason for a plot
that even even a photographer has to have a plot
a photographer is telling a story they're they're
trying to frame they're trying to frame a photo
they're they're looking for conflict they're
looking for they're looking for how how to present
it and it just made then to one person that just
like oh it's a picture of a face but if you talk
to the photographer they'll tell you what the
what the tension is and then so that we do
need tension I think for those writers that
do believe in and plot when it comes to plot
how can a writer figure out what isn't working
for it's I think that's in later rewrites throw
it all in there and then and then and what I what
I do is I is after I outline more after than
I do before so then I outline the scenes and
I kind of I was I want the I want the scenes to I
kind of think of it as a DJ so the the the heavy
conflict here is a nine and then let's get it
back down to a four then let's bring it up to a
seven as it's I used to DJ at bars and stuff too
in San Francisco with my crates of vinyl I want
to keep the Dance Floor going so how do I keep
the Dance Floor going I can't smash cut you know
I'm blanking on Fiona Apple to AC DC I probably
can but but how does how do they stay on the dance
floor so then they go buy more drinks so I get
more money at the end of the night from the place
so I think it's just about it's
about curating the scenes and then
and and just and and also the scene has to
make as you get towards your final draft
the scene has to make a case for itself is
this does the scene even make it into the movie
and it and I find it really intriguing that
this yes it makes it into the movie Yes it gets
shot yes it gets into post and even those scenes
get cut and and so the there's there's a reason
those scenes are written even if we have to take
them out when we're in the screenwriting process
there's a reason those scenes are filmed even if
they have to be taken out during post-production
and I don't know what that reason is and there's
probably producers going we're losing money and
when you do this but at the same time those
actors have to the actor and director have to
work through that scene that never makes it into
the movie but that may inform how another scene is
shot or how a character com actor comes at their
angle on another scene and for some I feel like
there's no they're they're there's a lot on the
there's a there's a lot of pages that you wrinkle
up and throw away and you're just like that didn't
work but you need it to get to where it works you
need it you need those and you need to embrace
those pages and you need and just go wow yeah you
almost have to say thank you to the bad writing
because the bad writing gets you to the good stuff
would you play Closing Time [Semisonic, 1998]
the end of your DJ sets I yeah the last I mean
I haven't DJ'd in so many years but the last
ones I did was I'd throw on a Frank Sinatra
or Tom Jones oh wow after after I've kept the
whole Dance Floor going and it's just kind of
like now we're mellowing out we're bringing
it down okay so yes the bartenders are trying
to do all their work to clean up and the last
call Ding last call I'm just like so in a movie
though you're also you're you're winding down
the audience whether it's a house wind down or
or a sad one or in some foreign film sort of an
ambiguous ending where we don't really know right
when it comes to plot and then the wind down
happens and we're a few minutes from the end
is there really a bad ending is there an ending
that this is not textbook how it should have been
if it's a happy story sad whatever yeah as I
think there's there's a film I just watched
where I was like oh that ending was so horrible I
can't remember what film it was darn it and it was
a good film there's a lot of films I really
love and I'm like oh you blew in the ending
and but as far as like as far as the stakes of act
three and the stakes of the high tension and then
we need the brat we all need to sit in it we all
kind of need to sit and relax and go wow and we
have to do that with the characters on the screen
and with everyone there's a there's a movie that
I bring to class especially my beginning classes
I make everyone and I've watched this hundreds of
times because I make everyone completely dissect
every single scene in it it's Little Miss Sunshine
and in Little Miss Sunshine I actually have the
I get the DVDs of the movie because I don't like
so I'm the DVD collector but they also have the
extras on there and they have the deleted scenes
and there was like one or two extra scenes at
the end of the movie that they completely shot
where there was like where they're like well
that was crazy they're they're like in a rest
stop and they're all on a bench and they're all
talking everything's just gone great and so oh
what do you want a hamburger and they shot this
whole scene but the end of the movie is the bus
driving away and it's the some people sometimes
you don't know what the end of the movie is until
it's way in post-production and and they didn't
know they thought they needed these tagons they
there's there's a lot of times where filmmakers
feel like they need to to hold the hand of the
audience a little more and the audience can hold
their own handle a lot of times the audience can
get it we don't have to we don't have to
kind of push it on them now feel like this
it's just like no stop that that was good enough
you're fine take a breath and think about that
I like that is do you think that just only comes
from seeing the actors play out that scene that
it's hard to tell on the page I don't know if it's
hard yeah it could be hard to tell on the page and
we're just trying to write the best story we can
with it's funny so with Confessions of a Teenage
Confessions of a Teenage Jesus Jerk I was from the
final draft I was very adamant about the ending
and I was like this is the ending this is
it and and there was a scene that was asked
to for afterwards and I'm just like no I didn't
want to write it and I and it had to be written
and then they shot it and then it didn't make the
film it didn't make the final cut and for some odd
reason maybe it did need to be shot so maybe maybe
I I've done so many things wrong and my Approach
has been sometimes my Approach isn't the greatest
approach sometimes I could be a little friendlier
and a little more amicable and go oh you're
right let's just do that and see what happens
but with this I was so sure that that was the end
but the the people involved weren't sure and it's
okay that they're not sure and so just let people
not be sure and then pray and post that it all
works out and and it may have been that depending
on how the tone of the film went because when that
edit when it's in the editing room it's being the
whole story is being told Again by an editor so
they may have needed to get that on camera just in
case they kept different scenes in there or they
had to lose scenes and but to get the whole tone
of the film they went nope that was the ending
so there's there's so many elements to how to end
a movie I mean I guess there it's and so much of
that stake so on the page the best you can do and
then does it end up in the Final Cut who knows
because there's so many there's so many
factors involved so so that's interesting
you you resisted sort of the suggested ending
they wanted an extra scene at the end and then
it ended up not happening and you ended up
agreeing that that was actually a good thing
to have that extra scene no no they shot the scene
and and then but but I won and then I won because
they that scene Hit The Cutting Room floor so
the movie ended exactly as I wanted it to end
does that make sense yeah and I wasn't sure if
you wanted The Cutting Room floor one you actually
agreed with them oh okay no no no I still I did I
still didn't agree and when I when I was sent the
rough cut as I was coming to the end I was going
yeah I had a I had to cut to Black it was cut to
Black like cut to Black cut to Black got the black
boom cut to Black and I was like yes so it was and
there were and there were other battles that I had
where I was like okay this is right and then and
I was totally wrong and so it's it there's that's
the beauty of the the collaboration of have those
disagreements because as the writer oh yeah I
can like pretend like I know everything but I
don't once you what's your once you're on set what
you're with a director once you're seeing actors
it's you you really got to kind of let things
go and yeah the only thing I was so I was really
adamant about was how the how it was going to
end and I just I saw that from the beginning and
and it wasn't it didn't make anyone feel
comfortable so maybe everyone needed to feel
comfortable and then they went no wait that's
right the ending is the cut to Black how did
fear of success almost ruin your writing career oh
fear of success ruins my writing career every day
it's yeah it's there's there's multiple fears
there's fear of success there's fear of failure
and I think I still self-sabotage
myself I have to get into a world of
it's a weird world of delusion where it's I
know I'm writing the greatest thing ever told
to man and through all of human history except
it's also a piece of crap at the same time
so fear I mean I guess there's there's fear of
success and fear of failure yeah it was I used to
I used to write everything with an Oscar
speech planned and and that Oscar speech
was more of who it wasn't who I was gonna think
it was who I hated and I was just gonna tell
I was going to bring all my resentments
out and it's it's silly and it's absurd
to think about but it would be fun to do an
Oscar speech but then you kind of look at it
and go ah but would it be really fun to go
to the Oscars but yeah fear fear of success
it's weird because I've had very minor success
I don't have a I don't feel like I have
I feel grateful for the success I've had but
in my very minor success it's sometimes it's
a little disconcerting or we're just like oh
crap yeah that's out there for people to see
oh and I forget and but at the same time that's
wonderful so what a what a bourgeois problems
are you gonna go to Starbucks and pay with two
credit cards after this I'm gonna pay with two
credit cards I'm gonna ask for water and I'm
gonna put ice in it and I'm like you're gonna
have to take this back and not put ice in this
okay right yeah do you almost feel guilty if
things go well for you what yes oh my God I have
therapy tomorrow too we're going to talk about
all of this I think a lot of that though it does
have to do with I grew up a Jehovah's Witness so
there is a lot of guilt in succeeding especially
in the entertainment industry there's a lot of
there's a lot of fear involved I'm working through
that actually constantly I'm working through the
mud The Merc and the mud of growing up in a way
where I was supposed to be not part of this world
and I wasn't supposed to buy into any of it and
my whole life was supposed to be devoted to the
church so I've been out for many years but it's
still back there and I still it still comes up so
and not that my story is totally unique I
think a lot of people have a have a rough
time with it because especially where you
come from working class family and it's
my grandfather Grandpa Duchesne I he lived a
mile away from me in San Francisco in the last
five years of his life I stopped talking to him
because I would go over there and he'd he would
insult me for my choices and saw me for writing
didn't understand why I didn't have a union job
like he had and and it was constantly insulting
and I was and I'm like I have enough of my own
self-doubt I don't need to be put down so much
so I basically cut him off out of my life and
and it was it's sad but I had to do it because
he wanted me to just be weighed down and then
plus he doesn't understand there's not there's
not a lot of money coming in this is this is
all an act of Faith but it's also not even on
the Act of Faith it's a it's a have to when you
realize you're a writer you have to write and it
doesn't matter if anything gets published and it
doesn't matter it's I'm a crappy person if I'm
not actively writing and in order to not be a
crappy person in this world I'm gonna keep writing
and then I'll be nicer to be around so interesting
so when you see a student in one of your classes
or a zooms sort of relationship and you can tell
like this person has some Talent it just needs
some refining but I'm seeing they almost they
feel guilty about like they feel like shameful
that they have talent what do you do to help them
sort of come out of that or you don't you figure
that's their own process you don't want to rush it
yeah I mean I just there's great talented people
that come through I'm there I'm there to I'm there
to help them with their craft and I'm there to
give them and to cheerlead them but at the same
time I'm also not their therapist so if they if
they have guilt if they I could come back I can
come in with hey this is what how this is what
I've worked through and this is and I usually
and this is what a lot of writers work through I'm
I get to I get to interview best-selling authors
all the time and they always feel like they have
imposter syndrome they can have 22 best-selling
books out that blank page still scares the crap
out of them but the one thing that they have ahead
of the person that has never written a book is
they remember the 22 best sellers every blank page
scared the crap out of them and then it went to
a bestseller so they know I remember this feeling
and I'm still gonna do it and I think that's
essentially all writing is to just know that
it doesn't feel good for a while and then it feels
good here and there and then it doesn't feel good
and it's yeah I wish it was sexier than that but
it's not you said just jokingly you always feel
shame writing something why is that yeah that
was was that a Freudian slip I don't know if
I don't always feel shame I just think that
there's just a feeling of it's a it's a it's the
working class in me it's the working class family
background it's why are my hands not calloused and
why are my joints not aching at the end of the
day where I've I've I've completely ruined the
tradition of the duches I'm not monkey wrenching
under a car monkey wrenching with a with a light
felted pen a legal paper and you can actually
make money and a living doing this how absurd
is this it's so maybe maybe my joke was probably
more because I was hiding the fact that I it's
not it's just weird to be a writer and from where
I've grown up it's weird to do anything that's not
mechanical or has has Union has very strong union
that so-called strong union that but I wasn't sure
if you meant to also exposing thoughts and things
about yourself that even if they aren't really
that controversial that it's just you're letting
people know your thought process right so that
shame I kind of don't have because my philosophy
is if it scares me it's the right thing so I'll
write things that scare me I'll write things that
I don't want anyone to ever know about me in my
life and but when I have that feeling of oh my
God nobody could ever know this that's when I
know I have to write it that's that's when I know
I have to go there and it's just hilarious that
once those things come out people go I feel that
way too and and it's everyone is just like how did
you write that I can never write that but I feel
the exact same way so the the beauty of just going
to the scary places I think that's that's what I
and I don't enjoy it but I do it and when I'm when
I'm scared to do it I know I'm doing something
right I know I'm heading in a good direction
what's more difficult writing a novel or
writing a screenplay oh good question there
they're both very different for me for so
for me I always write I write out scenes
so I don't write it I don't go straight to
the screenplay I can write the whole scene
and then I can I then I convert it to the
screenplay so I'm kind of always adapting
Pros to a script which is probably the worst
way to write a script but it's kind of the way
I approach it so for me the novel is always the
novel is always most important to me if someone
said you you gotta you gotta make a choice right
now are you writing novels for the rest of your
life are you writing a screenplays for the rest of
your life I immediately novels that's it I'm good
but I love film and I love the artist
screenwriting and I they both have their
challenges the the Beauty and the and they're
both beautiful in their own ways the beauty of
the novel is if you screw up a novel you screwed
up the novel and your name is on that if you may
if it's a great novel it's a great novel and your
name is on that so when you're the screenwriter
if the movie doesn't do that well there's
hundreds of people that could have
been part of the problem the movie does great
there's hundreds of people that could have been
part of the greatness so there it's one's a team
sport and one's a solo sport I can in both of them
in screenwriting it's a solo sport when you're
writing your script so I thrive in that and then
but I also thrive in problem solving I want them
to go through and give me notes and go scene 23
cut that out scene 42 we need this and I'm like
great and I need to know my screenplay back and
forth so I'll be like scene 23 we cut that out
that means that we're going to lose scene 18 and
this in the breadcrumb from scene three and so
it's that I love getting in the technical part
of that and I guess I do it with both I don't
find I don't they're both separate but they're
both so the same because we're both they're both
putting it on the page if that makes sense so with
screenwriting it's like a game of Jenga so if
you're pulling something from the bottom that
that's not going to make sense and and the whole
thing could topple unless it's properly weighted
it's got to be it's got to be constructed properly
or else yeah the whole thing is going to fall down
yeah same with the novel I mean you could totally
screw up a novel by going going too much or too
little there's the the technicals of it are
similar it's they just both have to be crafted
and the the beauty the beauty of Cinema is I
mean and we I think I see it a lot you see bad
screenplays that are good films because the
directors and the actors come in and if you
just really sat there and read the screenplay
and then you watch what the actors and the
directors brought to it and you go wow what a
crap screenplay but what a beautiful film and
there's there's a lot of bad screenwriters
out there that make great movies it's such an
interesting game yeah what about prose writing and
thought process versus screenwriting and thought
process in terms of showing the characters
going through something in their mind
they yeah that's when it was so when we're
when we're on the screenplay that's when
that's when we have to show we we show a lot
less there's a lot more breathing room so
the the novel where we're bringing we're bringing
the reader through the novel and through all
the internal process thought processes and the
screenplay where taking the characters there but
we also have to let the director do their job
and the actors do their job and we just kind of
have to and just give a little bit of intention a
little bit of note this happens this happens they
don't need to in the novel it could be oh why this
happened and it could go around this way but it's
get the essence of it just really put the
emotional Essence in there and not too much
emotional Essence because let the let everyone
let everyone do their job and they're gonna and
the and the the great directors do great work and
the great actors do great work and if you do put
too much in there you could be impeding what they
need to do on on their end as as part of their job
do novels and screenplays have the same
structure screenplays are I don't know because
you can really screw around with a novel structure
you can't screw around with the screenwriting
structure and anyone who's like oh wow this is
experimental and you look at it and yeah no it's
still 3x and I can tell you exactly where those
act breaks are because it's hard to break that
pattern we know we've been told these stories
through film for over a century a certain way
and if the First Act goes 45 minutes the
audience may not understand that the First
Act is going 45 minutes but they'll understand
that there's something wrong with the film and
I think I could just go to the bathroom and get
a some popcorn right now and they won't know why
so we are really structured to have the
the hero on the singular Journey for the
most part and the ACT breaks and the escalating
attention as it is with with the novel you can
Daniel epsky's House of leaves just that that
book right there just that turns the novel on
its side but it's a novel we can really there's
so much you can do to a novel that that can't be
done on screen as there's so much you can do on
screen that can't be done to a novel I mean you
can there's you you don't describe an actor
I mean you don't in the you don't describe a
character feeling sad and why they feel sad all
you got to do is see a look all you need is a
reaction on an actor's face and that will tell
you what five pages of the novel can tell you
so then that's when it's beautiful on the screen
and then when it's beautiful in the book too
yeah I've been looking at Walter Tevis's so the
Hustler and then The Queen's Gambit and then it's
been a while since I've actually seen the Hustler
but then seeing Queen's Gambit and just just the
differences just kind of like a lot of it was very
close to the novel maybe it was cleaned up there
were parts that were cleaned up more maybe for
certain audiences with the Queen's Gambit for for
the series it wasn't as there were some details
that were maybe too sexually explicit or whatever
but so just did she still see the chess on
the roof she did yeah I think so but it wasn't
totally I mean it was it was the because that
was where she took these these pills that yeah
she went into this world and that's how she
kind of disassociated and was able to take
herself out of the world of the orphanage in
bad situations and she would see that as a way
to not be in her reality yeah and so there was
that but yeah it's just interesting to compare
and and oftentimes usually the book it seems like
is is more enjoyable sometimes but then when you
see these characters come to life and you like the
actors yeah it's a whole another experience yeah
yeah anyway I'm not sure where I was going
with that but I'm not sure where I'm going
with anything so I'm glad I'm on the same
page and we're just having fun here okay so
how does a writer know if prose is better for
them creatively or the screenwriting format
I think it's I think they it's just trial and
error I wrote a screenplay in 2019 right before
covid and I was jazzed about it and I'm like
let's go let's go and I wasn't ready to show
it yet but I knew that I had because I knew I had
rewrites to do and then now I'm writing the novel
so I read the characters are intriguing me so much
I'm like I really need to get in their heads and I
really and and when I write I hand write I'm not a
typer so I have to handwrite everything and that's
and that's giving me so much joy right now because
that's just like I'm finding out things about the
theme and what I thought I was presenting
and it was just like oh no that's not the
theme at all so it's yeah it if something's
a screenplay or a book it could be both it's
and it could be just a novel
and some novels would be
really hard to adapt I but I think I would like
to think in myself if anyone asked me to adapt a
novel that was unadaptable I feel like I could
find the thread to do it but that's probably
because I get a little delusional and I want to
problem solved so so you love these characters
so much that you realized that 110 page whatever
screenplay wasn't wasn't enough for you creatively
yeah I think yeah I don't know if it wasn't
enough I think there's I don't think the
screenplay is there yet so that's part of it and
I think there's a lot more to explore and for me
the way to explore it is through pros and I'm
just doing it that way and in the end I mean it
might be a graphic novel who knows I it's almost
like you don't want to you don't want to put it
in a ball too quick let's just let the story go
let's let's see where the story goes and who who
knows it maybe it is just a book maybe maybe
it never was meant to be on the screen at all
or maybe the book gets tossed away and I learn a
couple things and go back in the rewrite I don't
think we should I don't think we should hold
on to the the medium so much that work through
it and try to complete things but we shouldn't
we I don't think we need to give the medium so
much power let's give the story The Power was
there a defining book of your teenage years
so I really couldn't read books in my teenage
years because I grew up the Jehovah's Witness
and I was reading more bible stuff and the
and only slid by in the books that were
that were assigned to us in school so
and they essentially were like just
try to read enough so you can get by and
get a decent grade and get out it was it
was very discouraged to read anything that
wasn't published by the Jehovah's Witnesses
when so when so what happened was a friend of mine
a friend of mine in the Jehovah's Witnesses was
disfellowshipped so he was shunned and then he
killed himself and so I went to the elders and I
was looking for help and because I was because I'm
like wait Gibby killed himself and how can I not
kill myself because I do have suicide in my family
that's not related to the Jehovah's Witnesses so
they were completely unhelpful they didn't want
me to grieve his suicide they just said make
sure you keep going and preaching and stay and
that was not the answer for me so what I did and
this was I think I was 22 or 23. so so I went to
the library instead and I went to the psychology
section and I'm like where do I get help so I
found Tony Robbins and I found a Wayne Dyer oh
yeah and I'm like and I and I was like oh and I
would just sit there in the stacks and read these
and it kind of gave me a little bit of perspective
and then it was next to poetry and I started and
I just started opening poetry books and and now
it's just and they were speaking to me and then
somehow the first novel I read was Giovanni's room
James Baldwin so I read that book kind of didn't
get it because it's a homosexual love affair if
I remember right I haven't read it since then
but I got the I got the heart of it it meant
something to me and I was like who do I read
next so James Baldwin was my number one and then I
read Henry Miller and then I found out that there
was this guy Jack Kerouac who was grew out on the
road and it was it was the Beat Generation I'm
like what's a beat and I remember skateboarding
to the library before it closed because I had to
get a copy of on the road that weekend and read
it and I read that and I went and and these were
touching me on emotional levels it was I was
having a conversation with authors that had
died but they were but they were I was having a
conversation that I never got to have in my life
and that that's what changed everything and
then I read a book called hunger by Newt ham
soon this Norwegian author and that's when I went
I'm a writer that was the book where I just went
that's it I'm a writer and I'm going full in and
even if I can't eat and I have to die I'm writing
till the end so and when did you tell family
people in the church that you were a writer
well I was still married and I was married so I
ended up getting married to a Jehovah's Witness
and I was still married I told her that out and
she begged me not to tell anyone and I didn't and
that was very codependent of me but I was also
I was also unhealthy at the time as well but I
was writing at the time and I was and I started
a thing called film junkie and and I would go to
film festivals I knew all of a sudden I was a
journalist in 1999 I was like this is all you
got to do so I was going to these see all these
movies before they were raided because you can't
watch rated R movies in the Jehovah's Witnesses
and then I was writing about all these movies and
then but then they would come out and be rated
R and they'd be like how did Tony see that and
they're like well it wasn't rated yet and they'd
be like oh okay when I was kind of out of the out
of it so I was actively like writing and working
on my own stuff and it was starting to get seen
around and people would get in touch with my wife
at the time and be like Tony's kind of you wrote
something that didn't seem a little too Christian
maybe you should talk to him about it and
then I would lean in harder and write a sex scene
so because I was being very contrarian at the time
and I think I needed essentially I was getting
my teenage angst out when I was 27 which is just
totally embarrassing you need to get it out in
your teen years but it was a little later for me
so then you moved to LA and you felt like that you
could be your own person and and that you didn't
feel shame about writing anything oh I feel shame
about writing everything I did the LA move didn't
happen for a long time I stayed in San Francisco
I was writing for the San Francisco Chronicle so
I was covering books and music for the chronicle
and I wasn't planning on moving to Los Angeles
and then I finished Confessions of a Teenage
Jesus Jerk and then I was shopping it around
I got an agent and then I got a publisher and
then so that the book came out and then the
option thing started happening where things
go to die so so but it but it was beautiful
I got to work with producer who runs hunting
Lane films Jamie patrickoff and we worked on
the pitch for the TV series and and I learned
so much about like writing pitches taking notes
getting and he's very gracious with me and
and then it was just like that kind of just
fizzled out there there's like meh no screw it
and I don't think it was him I think it was the
people that he had interested and then and then
the book got to Eric Stoltz and then that's when
he he said hey let's first off I found out
Eric Stoltz was reading my book and I was
just like well I could just die now we're done
and then yeah and then he said we need Tony to
write the screenplay so we don't lose the
voice and I went and I went challenge taken
so I yeah I worked on that really
hard and hours and hours on end
and so I wasn't oh so I wasn't in La yet I was I
was in San Francisco and he was he's in New York
so we were doing a lot of back and forth that
way and then as it went in it got delayed and
then shooting was supposed to start another time
it got delayed but I knew I had to be in La for it
and so I just got down to La when it was in
pre-production and I sublet my apartment in
San Francisco and I just would sublet around La
while I was in pre-production and then and some
months later we were on set and on location so
that's how I came to La I was already very far
out of the Jehovah's Witnesses I was already
divorced I was I had already created a writing
life in San Francisco and I was I knew it
was time to leave San Francisco but I was
kind of thinking New York because I was writing
for Publications and going on that angle but
the nudge to La brought me here which was it
turned out to be the right choice and yeah
how does the book business differ to the film
business is it well what what I've noticed is
in the book world there's not a lot of people
are there for all the for all the huge amounts
of cash coming in there there's kind of more of
a a passion like oh crap we might have picked
the wrong thing but this is what we love so when
I'm working with like an editor I'm working with
an agent there's a deep love the agent wants to
make money then these people yeah they do want
to make money but they're kind of there because
it's just what what they what they know and what
they're good at when we get to film there's a
there's a little bit more the film business is
weird I I I really don't connect with the film
business that much at all I'm not good at the
film business and so it's I'm kind of not even
good at pitching I'm not good there's a lot of
things I'm really not good at on the film side
of things but but I know but I know that I
know the I know my the story is the only thing
that really that I really care about and then
the maniacal passion to get it out there when
I feel like I've got it right so and and I've
people in the people in the film business they're
nuts they're just absolutely nuts and it and what
I've learned is it's just hilarious how people are
like oh yeah no that's I'm Indie we will never do
Studio work and it's like oh we're studio and it's
just like there are pieces of crap on every single
layer and sometimes those Indie sometimes those
Indie focused people are the ones you don't want
to work with at all to be much better to work at
Paramount and sometimes it's vice versa there's
the game is just funny there's just what I've
learned is what what I've learned in my my small
career so far is to is to just love who you
work with and but in the film industry that
might not be an option and have a really good
entertainment lawyer that spells everything
out and you don't even have to talk to some people
sometimes even if you're working with them just so
well that was going to be my next question
is can you love film and love wanting to put
something out there but not love the business and
not really want to be a part of the business does
that it seems like that can't work out well
I'd love to be a part of the business where
the checks are big that's my favorite part of
the business I would love to be a part of that
hey the business needs to be done and I understand
why the business needs to be done I mean to create
a film is a Monumental expense and people are
putting their money and going okay let's make
profit and so the stakes are very high and it's I
nobody knows what's going to make it what or like
William Gold was it William Goldman or just like
nobody knows anything but they make good guesses
and there's a lot of people that make good guesses
I do I mean I love the art of film I I love the
passion of someone who's in wardrobe and to talk
to someone who does wardrobe and and it's just
like they are storytellers there and I've learned
a lot coming into this where my I've Loved film
before I love it even more now that I've seen
behind the curtain so that yeah there's the
business part but but most of this most of the
time if you're really working on something the
business part's so secondary and you you try to
get agents and entertainment lawyers to do all of
that part of it and then go okay great here's
what I need to do and this is what I need to
deliver and I think a lot of that is communication
too I'm I've I think I've learned a lot over the
years be very almost over communicative so they
know what to expect so they know what I can bring
and don't promise anything that I can't bring
but let them know that I'm going to try to do
that but that might be out of my realm but let's
just see what happens kind of thing so so then
with the literary World maybe New York old money
sort of this this closed network is that a fallacy
it's much more open now it's oh I don't know
yeah I just might be with the cool people okay
I mean I don't know on the publishing end I guess
I know just a lot of writers so who are just
lovely people whether they're a bestseller every
time they come out or they're on a small print run
and I love both of their styles of writing equally
and love them in their own ways as people so I
think maybe I know more the writing end and I get
to kind of be aloof to the to where the business
is I kind of just don't I don't care too much
and I'm dealing with publicists a lot because
I cover writers and the publicists are great
too for the most part they're just passionate
about the the writing and they're they want to get
their they want to get their authors out there and
which publicist I've worked with for 20 years
that that they they know who to give me they
just go you're going to love this guy and I'm like
great you're gonna love this girl I'm like great
I don't even need to see the book just just yeah
they're on the calendar so the the passion for it
is there I want to talk to writers I say I want to
talk to right and that's the lovely thing of doing
a podcast is someone if I went hey I want to talk
to you to just that random out of the blue they'd
be like who who are you you have a podcast and
you're like I'd love to talk to that person for
an hour and pick their brain and it's just like
wait you can just do it it's just it's good fun
and that's drinks with Tony yeah and you've been
doing it how long the next year will be 20 years
so I'm putting together the 20-year anniversary
party but I did have the Hiatus for five years
between 2013 and 2018. so why the Hiatus that's
when Confessions of a Teenage Jesus Jerk went into
development and then I had to get to La and I used
to do drinks with Tony in studio in San Francisco
so that was that was a two-hour show in studio
and I didn't know how to do it not in studio
and then after all the film that for
the film was released and that kind of
that that kind of dust settled then I went maybe
I should just do this as a podcast and have my
field recording gear instead of worrying about
being a doing a two-hour show so I just kind of
switched up the format the way you miss writing
and the way you feel like you're a better person
for writing and when you don't it's kind of
like the people that meditate they're like oh
if I don't meditate I'm not fun to be around were
you similar with not being able to do the podcast
did you need did you miss that did you
need to do that podcast so well so after
after Confessions of a Teenage Jesus Jerk came
out and after all the dust settled I was walking
up Hillhurst totally depressed I just gutted I
didn't know why and I'm like how do I get out
of this depression and I'm like what's the last
thing that made me happy as I was like as I was
working on other writing projects and stuff but
and I went drinks with Tony and I think I think
because there's no stakes in it from you there's
stakes in it because I want to do a good show
but there's no there's not the stakes that I'm
putting into my writing and at the same time
and I and I restarted it with thinking oh maybe
I'll get 10 episodes in I wasn't planning on
doing it that long I was just like oh I still got
this and I got public publicist contacts I'll just
tell people I'm doing it again and then
when I don't get a guess I'll just stop and
I just put episode 157 up because the guests
haven't stopped coming and I have to say no
to a lot of people so it's just like oh but and
I still enjoy it and the only reason I do it is
because I really enjoy it it's the one in ten
guests I go ugh that that felt like a piece of
crap but the nine out of ten I'm just like oh
this is why I do this and there's like two out
of ten where I'm like this is really why I do this
this is this reminds me of why I'm in this game so
whereas with writing if you don't write explain
to me how long before you suffer withdrawal
it's I think it's I think I think the thing the
thing is is I need to have characters in my brain
and I need characters that are coming together
so I need to actively be working on someone so
I'm working on a character Amber right now and
so in the during the day I can have things that
irritate me but I have the problem solving of how
will Amber get out of this situation who what is
Amber what else does what else does she need what
what is what does she want to say to the world so
it's maybe it's a way to avoid the the conflict
happening around me where I can kind of almost
meditate on this character that I'm working
on and this that I may that this character
actually kind of don't like but as I'm writing
her I'm writing her completely out of love and
just building around her and she's she's a yeah
I mean what this is this is yeah this is a writer
in process on a character but this character
does not make great choices and this character
continues to make great choices and in the end
she still doesn't make the great choice she's
so there's but working with her and kind of really
getting in her head is just a lot of fun and just
and what swirls around her is I find interesting
why do you love her if she makes these bad choices
I'm well I'm setting up a it's there's
another character that I'm working
on that's going to get the a that's
going to be more of the protagonist
and it's a story of three characters
but there's this one character that
is more pivotal than the others so the
characters are around him need to really be
three-dimensional and now and I also want I love
the ambiguity of in my head she's not making the
right choices but as we get as we get as we move
through the story maybe she is making the right
choices it's it well in the end she's doing
the best she can with the information she has
but as far as I'm concerned it's that character
is someone that's not that's not that hasn't
reached the maturity or reached a certain level of
understanding but has stayed in it and so I have
empathy for that and that's so yeah so driving
here I'm I'm just like driving and I'm thinking
of Amber and people are like oh who who's Amber
is that your girlfriend I'm like no it's a it's
just a word on a page but you have a vision of
what she looks like what her hopes are what her
fears are what her triggers are yeah yeah yeah and
as I keep writing her I find out more about her
and that's that's the joy of that's the joy of
prose writing for me because I can I can find
out if I'm as I write and I write the scene now
and I go oh that's why she's doing that it was
I had on this particular one in the in the in
the screenplay she's she's looking in a mirror
and reflecting on herself and that was like
the only thing and as I wrote the thing out
she's worried about aging she's in
her 20s and she's worried about aging
and and it's and and that kind of clicked and I
went and it create it opened her up and it opened
the whole story up in a new way where it's just
like I'm not gonna put in the screen now if it if
the if the prose gets thrown away and it stays in
the screenplay I'm not putting in the screenplay
she's worried about aging but I know she's
worried about aging when she looks in the mirror
she's a model or cocktail waitress or makeup
artist oh okay all right yeah okay do you ever
see her anywhere do you ever see like oh that
was Amber no no I didn't no I don't see her I see
her enough I mean when I'm writing the script you
just I see her enough and I don't want to cast her
I like that to be very open but I do
have my thoughts on certain things
but as far as like describing exactly who she
is and what she looks like there's there's just
little Composites here and there and and I'll
take out like pages from like magazines and
stuff and it's there's there's an idea but it's
not that but it's there could be something that
a certain a certain photograph is just like oh
that's kind of an essence of what she could be
and yeah it's I'm not one to really describe
I don't care much about what they look like I
care more about the insides I guess and then
for the film it's there's casting directors
for that who could tell me way better who could
they're much better with at that gig than I am so
are most great stories and Outsider story
I don't know I mean I feel like I feel like
I'm an outsider and I feel like almost
everyone I know feels like an outsider
at some point in their life if not often
probably more than 50 percent of the time
so maybe that's why we can kind of gravitate
toward Outsider stories yeah and it it's we
look at a film like Mean Girls or something and
it's about people just trying to be together
and fit in it's we have this urge to we have this
urge to be together and part of the tribe and so
the the outsider's story is fun to play with but
I don't think any of us want to be an outsider
but it's fun to watch The Outsider because
we kind of can we feel like we're Outsiders
that makes sense it does I'm trying to think of
the movie I just watched from the is it Pump Up
the Volume the question oh yeah yeah and so
here he's this radio guy and everybody kind
of worships him because he just says whatever he
wants yeah and they can't believe what they're
hearing and then the The Faculty is just incensed
by it and then in real life he's this awkward guy
that he wants he he wants to be part of the
group but then he's kind of turned off by
that whole Suburbia High School hierarchy thing
and just had me thinking about that just sort of
this guy that actually when you listen to him he
spoke to everyone but then for whatever reason he
was too scared at the the high school to yeah
try to navigate the social hierarchy yeah and
but but we we have these these Hero Stories
where are they always The Outsider I guess
maybe that's what makes the hero's Ark
is that I guess yeah I guess in order for
I mean for the most part when we have our
heroes journey and I think it's singular hero
I think it's because we could we can relate
to the problems of one person for 90 minutes
if you bring in too many people or the the
ensemble cast there tends to be a veering
towards the one person that's really pushing
it all the way through so we we have to have
that we almost have to have that mirror who's my
mirror here oh it's Cameron Diaz okay great I'm
with her on this journey and that's and I don't
think that's real life in any way at all but for
well we're all our own heroes in our own Journeys
but we're also a collective but so I guess our
protagonist is an outsider of sorts because the
protagonist needs to be spun around they need to
be pushed back on their heels and that's why we're
interested it's just like oh wait they spun around
they're dizzy how do they stop being dizzy okay
that's fun now how do I turn the page or sit here
for another 10 minutes to find out what the next
two scenes are because that was interesting what
Peril is this character going to be in so yeah
it would make sense that the characters would be
Outsiders this during covid we we have all these
the the movies I've watched have not been movies
I would watch there are Comfort movies and the
wrong Missy came out the David Spade movie that
Adam Sandler produced and and it's not a movie I'd
go run to see but I watched it and it's just he is
he is an outsider he's he's in his own tragedy
it's a comedy but he's in the utter tragedy of
thinking that he found the it's really formulaic
and like you like if I just told you two or three
description you'd be like oh so the act one is
this act two is this act three is this it's like
yeah it is but it's fun to watch him get there
what movie protagonists do you do you feel the
most connection to huh it could be male or
female well so when I was young and this was
there was this movie called Johnny swade Brad Pitt
starred in it that came out and Tom dicillo wrote
it and I look at it now and it's absurd and it's
hilarious but at the time I was I thought I was
Johnny suede I am it's it was Brad Pitt's first
leading role and and it's just about a guy who's
trying to figure out love and
wants to get a band together
I'm like that's me and it's just kind of silly
because it's a he's really kind of a Dopey
character and not I don't know why I gravitated
to him so much I think I think it was because I
was trying to figure out love and was kind of
always wanted to have getting a band together
is like getting a group of friends together just
like how do we how do we how do a bunch of guys
come together and not make love well let's
just get a band it's I it's everything's kind
of intimacy so he was trying to find his
intimacy and blowing it beyond belief and
so when I think of a character that I gravitated
to when I was when I was young it was it was
Johnny Suede and I had the yeah it's a Tom de
chilo I got to interview him like 15 years ago
and he's written books too and I brought every
single book I'm like please sign my books now
he lives in La so I still have to like yeah
anyway he's he's I'm a huge fan of his and
I'm a huge fan of how honesty is about his career
as a filmmaker and how really rough and tumble it
was and just the beauty of Johnny Suede and
his other movie living in Oblivion which came
out after that so and sorry you were still in
the church at the time you saw it okay yeah and
you didn't tell anyone that you saw the movie
I was very careful yeah because it was rated R
so I had to go to the video store actually I
think I bought the VHS I bought the VHS and that
and I watched that thing that's probably
the movie I've seen the most in my life
and I could probably give you every line of
dialogue from here the reason I watched it was
because one of my favorite singers is in Nick
Cave so that was what turned me on to it and
then all of a sudden I'm like well that character
spoke to me so would you hide the movie Somewhere
yes yeah yeah hide the hide the movies hide
the records yeah where would you hide them
yeah yeah not to I actually have my own apartment
at that time oh okay so it was easy enough but
when I was like still living at home it was
records were behind the dresser and we would
make mixtapes for our friends and then we would
hide the mixtapes but we would all trade the tapes
and then we would keep the records at certain
friends houses moving back and forth wow and
it's just because they were rated R that was for
music and that's because they were punk rock and
that was something that would that no one would
understand movies I know movies I wouldn't even
bring into the house that were rated R but I
would try to I would I would go to the video
store and this was this was when I was married I
go to the video store and then I would like look
around to make sure no one from the congregation
was around and then I would like and then I'd pick
up oh look at this rated G movie well this looks
very this looks very good yeah I like this G movie
can you put that in there too because I want
to know what Martin scorsese's done and then
yeah then I went to the library constantly
and was just checking out every movie that
stuff like I'd never seen apocalypse now and
it's just I never even I didn't know what a
war movie was I thought war movie was just
violence and terrible and it's just like oh
no these are crafted films and so but I would have
to watch them on my own and be very careful yeah
how do you define story and how do you teach it to
students and clients we tell stories all the time
even as I'm talking to you I'm telling stories I'm
bringing characters in we where we're made to tell
stories we're made to we're made to tell stories
about what our Aunt did that oh my God she's she's
crazy she's out of her mind what she did and
so we're story building constantly just even
even if we don't know it and then that's when we
go okay so how do we craft it and then it's just
like let's that's when I talk about character
and plot let's talk about a character okay what
does this character do let's talk about plot and
then what I do this I do a free writing workshop
for the library once a month and so it's one of my
favorite things to do because I get nobody I know
in there it's just like all of a sudden I have
all these eyeballs looking at me going teach us
how to write a story and and sometimes they have
a lot of experience and sometimes it's the first
time they've ever even thought of being a writer
and so right away I just talk about character
and plot and the what drives me nuts about
there's Monumental catalog of books out there
500 pages how to create a plot into screenplay
500 pages character work I throw all those out
there's not it we can't be bogged down by this
intellectual this is how it is and Blake blank
blank blank blank it is good to read those books
I mean I'm a fan of Joseph Campbell I'm a fan of
I'm a geek about storytelling but as far as as far
as it's concerned just start writing and just have
a character and just give them a goal and then
just get in the way of the goal and just see what
happens and then what I do is I do free writing so
I'll do a free writing exercise so I'll just put
that I'll have them do a free write and then they
usually don't know that there's a second and third
part I'll throw in the plot twist for them and
and then they're and then they they create kind of
full-fledged stories within 30 minutes on the end
there's a beauty to that it's there's a beauty to
having a time limit and then just going what you
all wrote crap everything you wrote is problematic
and awful I can't wait till you bore me with your
story because what you wrote is you it took you
30 minutes there's people that write for years to
write a good short story so let's let's see what
happens and usually they're all very interesting
they're it's way more interesting than anyone
would ever think and so that's that's kind of how
I wanted I want people to just jump into it and
write a story in 30 minutes and then kind of
walk away and go I can do it and this is like
yeah you can but you kind of got to do it every
day and it's got to be a practice like anyone
could anyone could do yoga they might but you're
not going to go do a handstand on the first day
if you've never done yoga in your life you got
to come and practice every day you gotta teach
your body so when you're writing you got to teach
your mind teach your mind that you're coming to
the page you're coming to the page and your mind
starts to go oh crap we're coming to the page I
better come up with something so yeah can you
give me an example of let's suppose what a free
writing sort of assignment the in five minutes
Karen I need you to and you you would have me
write something out what would it be so what what
I so here's an assignment that I get that I give
is I asked I would say Karen what what would
be the greatest job in the world that you could
ever have and think of anything anything at all
what would you like to do for eight hours a day
and then I would hear what you would like to
do for eight hours a day and I'd be like great
on this scenario you're going to get 50 million
dollars a year to have this job but you only have
one more you've been through eight interviews
they want you you have one more interview
so you need to you need to drive to the interview
but when you as you're driving to the interview
you're gonna get a car accident and someone's
going to cut you off and so right and I would tell
you to write that write that scene you got the
last interview for the greatest job in the world
for all the money you could ever want but this
car cut you off and that would be the beginning
of that writing exercise and then the plot twist
that everyone write it out and usually it's just
like that that just I'm gonna cool and oh and it's
just great they like really get into it because
they find something they're passionate about the
character right it's we've created the character
the character has a passion and the character
has a goal and then after that that limit I go
okay great now you're now your character's at
the interview and they find out that the person
they got in the car accident with is the person
that's interviewing them now how does that play
out and that's when it's just like because they
weren't thinking of that there and so then they
then they're like oh how do we how do we resolve
this huge problem now usually that has been a very
contentious scene is now the person that they
need so it's a lot of fun and then after that
my big question is that the last sentence is do
they get the job or do they not get the job and
usually it's 50 50. so usually people find a way
around it people it's so that would be that that
would be one of the the one of the one of the
lessons I use a lot to get someone to write and
that would be about 30 minutes so I'd have them
write about 10 minutes just really dive into the
anger of the scene 10 minutes of resolution
and then five minutes after that so excellent
that sounds fun yeah I know sometimes the beauty
of being in a writing class is just hearing the
other people it's not it's not so much getting
critique on your own yeah and in that situation
there's no critique at all because it's just re
it's just reading it oh I see okay so and and for
the most part everyone is laughing at every story
because they're so good and it's and people get
really like I've had people who are like that
is the first time I have ever read anything
I've written in front of everybody it happens more
than not and like were you expecting that reaction
they're like no and I'm like you got story to tell
so make a decision you're going to join us in hell
what is it laugh with the Sinners or cry with
the Saints Virginia come on yeah no I don't
know why I'm singing I shouldn't be singing
why are you allowing me to do this no no
but at Village I would join in if I knew it
I gotta watch Mystic Pizza I gotta listen to
Billy Joel if we were to have a Tony Duchene five
part writing process to a story what would that be
I don't know why I'm drawing a blank a
pen paper okay yeah pen paper good cup
of coffee or whatever or whatever drink and
a desk or even a chair just somewhere and
whether you're disturbed or not Disturbed I think
something that happened with covid is people said
oh it must be great for you because you can right
now like you want I'm like no no no you don't get
it I have to be irritated right people are not I
need to be in a cafe where people are talking loud
on their cell phones people are being awful and
I have to tune that out and then I have to write
I have to kind of write in in situations where
it's kind of antagonistic where things are coming
at me and that's when I do my best writing
when I'm at peace I don't do great writing
so yeah yeah no the certain coffee shops are great
for conflict and for oh and it has to be boring
people are like oh do you have intelligence yeah
I'm like oh no I'm at Coffee Bean they're just
like why would you go there and like because
it's boring and corporate oh so you don't want
too much too much happening I don't want it to be
cool oh I see okay yeah yeah I don't want it to
be hip okay so no filtered water and yeah erotica
beans or what you've got to have more just I mean
my coffee bean has great coffee so yeah you just
want something where it's not there's not hipsters
coming in all the time well no it's it I just I
don't want the whole place to be a fashion show
you know hipsters are not I mean people look at
me and people look at me and sometimes oh great
there's a hipster here I get it well sometimes
what's great are old diners I know they're hard
to find where there's someone that I'll be right
with you and it's like they're gonna serve it from
one of those ancient coffee pots and that's great
because there's so many characters in a place like
that and it's real quiet and there's just everyone
like each person has a fascinating story like what
they're doing and yeah but there's not that many
places like that anymore they've been replaced
what writing failure has taught you the
most it's funny I my the first novel I wrote
it's terrible but I think you have to write
it to learn how to write a novel it's like
you have to write a screenplay to learn how
to write a screenplay so you just have to fail
same time you kind of gotta as you come to your
first novel you have to think oh it's going to
be published it's going to be great oh everyone's
gonna love it I'm a novelist just like and then
you're just like a year or two in and you're like
yeah I can't do anything with this I got nothing
but you you've put in the time and you kind of
get the idea of what needs to be done in order to
to write to write a novel so did you think it
was bad or did other people say it no I thought
it was bad and I it was bad it was it was all
over the place yeah I was so what was it about
it was it was about a marriage that was breaking
up and yeah it's funny because it was like night I
wrote it like nine years before my marriage broke
up so maybe I was just foretelling my future but
yeah it's I was young and precious I think I think
if I'm precious with my work that's when there's
a problem I can't be precious do you think you
cared about the novel too much I think I cared
about the the the the label of me as a novelist
too much I think I was a little too hyped on that
there's there's a beauty to there's a beauty
to what's interesting is once like once I got
published and then your book comes out there's
a whole oh is that all there is and that's that
Peggy Lee song is that all there is to book
publishing except it's different words but
but it that's that's the greatest Club to be
in because then you talk to other writers and
you're just like oh hey yeah how's your book when
it's out and that's that's usually the thing it's
they could be or they could be excited it's on the
best seller list but they got 12 interviews to do
that day and it's like so there's still that oh
okay I gotta get I got to get in this mindset of
actually caring about a book that I finished
a year ago and it's bougie problems I guess
do you think people feel the same once
their film comes out or that's different
the when when Confessions of
a Teenage Jesus Jerk came out
so well I got to see the rough cut and then
when I when then when I saw it at the first
film festival it was at I didn't I didn't
know what the Final Cut was going to be
so when I so when I was there it was fun to watch
but then I was realizing that I was trying I was
I was gauging the audience I was I was listening
to the audience more than I was watching the movie
because I wanted to make sure the jokes were
landing and I wanted to make sure that when there
was supposed to be silence there was silence
and so that's how that worked and then I saw
it one more time at another Festival and and I
did the same thing and I was just like all right
what's what jokes what jokes are landing
what's working what's not working and it
was kind of consistent I was like ah okay I'm
just a screenwriter I'm not the director but
when he he was there too and then and then
after that I there was another screening and
I just stayed for the First Act I was waiting
for one punch line to see if the audience got
it and then they all got it and then
I left and came back later to do q a
I don't know if I've ever seen it again in its
entirety and it's a weird relationship because I
I see the film and I see where I go oh I was right
off camera to the left oh that's the day that that
associate producer got in a fight with the unit
production manager oh that's that's the day that
I was hiding behind the truck out of to make sure
I was out of frame but I can see that it's so
my relationship to it is it's it's it's
almost incestuous it's almost too much to see
and it's very happy with it but it's a little
disconcerting I guess so again and I got to see it
in production so seeing it in production is
a very different experience and a very lovely
experience I think that was my favorite part of
the experience is to see the different takes and
the different choices the actors are making
and I'm looking at Eric and going oh my God
they're making me look good and he'd be like
they're making both of us look good yeah so
yeah if the audience hadn't laughed at that
one punch line what would have happened
I probably would have been we've
totally failed utter failure yeah
those yeah I had definite punch lines in mind
and a lot of them are lead actors Sasha had to
deliver and he did great and yeah it's it worked
so sure but sometimes audiences don't you we've
all been in a film where we're the only ones
laughing and we're like why are why am I the
only one that's laughing here yeah yeah that's
on that example I mean I and but at the same
time that movie was everything to me because
that movie was about me that movie was my life
and that book was my life so it was the
it was a I wasn't sure if I should write
it as a memoir I mean I was writing it as
a novel to test it out as a novel and I
wasn't sure if I should pull out some of
the fictitious things to make it a memoir
when it was still in book form but it read better
as a novel to me and it read better with more more
leniency into facts of the world up now I was
a journal I was a journal I took a journalistic
approach to the world of the Jehovah's Witnesses
so I made sure everything was absolutely factual
to the to the nth degree across the board so I
actually had to do a lot of research on that but
that movie was that movie was Me growing that
movie was all me and so that movie was the most
that will be the most important movie probably
of my career because that's the story I needed to
tell and I needed to tell it that way and not in
the woe is me oh my God I grew up in a restrictive
religion no I don't want I didn't want that I
wanted the levity of there's of the okay and
why people are there and I wanted I wanted more
I didn't want a definitive answer and to a lot of
to a lot of there's extra Jehovah's Witnesses
out there who do not like the movie because I
did because I portrayed the Jehovah's I don't
say anything bad about the Jehovah's Witnesses
and I'm like that's on purpose because this is a
just a character study and it's essentially me so
how does that character differ from Johnny swade
yeah yeah yeah that's the fictional character I
should have clung on to so the character's name's
Gabe and he's he's just Earnest he's trying to
just find his truth and he's trying to live in
it and he's trying to stay a Jehovah's Witness
and that's kind of what I did I was trying to
find my way to stay in because I believed it
through my soul so but I also wanted to feel okay
around people who weren't Jehovah's Witnesses and
I also just wanted love so a lot of that is just
the yearning for for someone to be in love with
and me as a I know the backstory of me because
when I was six years old I was engaged to Pamela
because I asked her to marry me and she said yes
I just I was very I was very romantic and it just
had this yearning for family and that's how I saw
my way out of feeling bad of it's like oh when I
have a wife then I'll feel better as a Jehovah's
Witness and so the Confessions of a Teenage Jesus
Jerk doesn't go that far into it Confessions of
a Teenage Jesus Jerk is kind of ten years of my
life smashed into a six months so but Johnny Swede
he forgive me I'm gonna now I'm gonna go watch the
movie because now you have me intrigued I want
to see and who doesn't want to see a Brad Pitt
movie so what would what about that character do
you wish could have been you I don't know if I
wish it could have been me I think I just related
to him because he's kind of dumb but he's earnest
so there's just like he's making mistakes left
and right and the not that time in my life
it was pretty tumultuous because that was around
the same time that my friend had died and I was I
think I was just looking for something and I think
the character like Johnny suede was trying to just
fit into something and he just he just wanted he
really just wanted a girlfriend and he was he just
and he wasn't mature enough to understand when
the right girl was right in front of him that it
was right and and it just it yeah so that all kind
of made sense to me what mistakes do writers make
when writing characters I don't know if they make
mistakes writing characters well maybe they do
um let's just find ways to
make them three-dimensional
and there's always ways and I think that's when
I think in the end your character just needs
we need to know what the
character's goal is and then just
make it harder for them that's that's
about it so for the most part it's
yeah it's I think I think I do find some people
are that then this is one that comes oh no this
is based on a true story and no this is a real
person and it's just like okay but get back to
the get back to the page stop doing the verbatim
on but I also think that's a technique that
technique that's a very great word for it it's a
way for people to avoid actually writing it's a
way for them to avoid actually sinking into the
conflict of the possibilities of that character
so they can just say oh no this really happened
and it's just like you just don't want to go there
that's okay don't be a writer it's not a it's not
a hugely paying gig unless it is sometimes it's
mostly sad it's it only looks pretty in movies so
why wouldn't what where would they not want to go
I mean I find this I find this a lot
and I find this in the majority of
maybe 70 of the students that take my classes
they they don't want to they it's like when
we were talking about the the evilness and
the Darkness I don't think they want to go
into the darkness of their characters
because they're too scared to show the
darkness of themselves and that's when we're
gonna completely that's that's just when the
the the the cat the sand castle of The
Story You're creating just won't work it's
you need to know the imperfections that's that's
the the fun part right so they make this character
too perfect or or it's too flat yeah too flat
and just it doesn't yeah it's just it's reading
like they're avoiding and usually I'll ask
them what they're avoiding and oh no no this
really happened and there's people there's
a lot of students who just don't want notes
and you just kind of find them and go all right
well you're not getting notes then it's just
like oh my my standard is oh well thanks for
sending this in and just sprinkle more conflict
if a student's getting that note from me that
means that I realize they're not taking any
notes and they just want a participation grade so
so if I let's suppose I turn something in and and
you you give me a first passive first round of
notes and then you see that I don't integrate
or I don't change anything is that mean I'm not
receptive no it's it usually the I don't mind I
don't mind if a student's confused I don't mind if
a student is even offended like whoa wait a second
but the the con then the conversation let's have
the conversation and and it doesn't mean that they
need to become take every note and become great
in the next scenes but but you could start to tell
after a few workshops where you're just
like it just it just happens there's the
practice is happening it's just like oh you're
hitting it you're hitting it you're hitting that
conflict you're you're hitting this I'm seeing
what you're doing and here and here and here
you could just you could tell when someone's
avoiding truth almost and when someone just
and that and that's that's the one thing that
I really kind of preach to every writing class
that I teach is write your truth I can give you
an outline with 90 I can give you 90 story Beats
with the character with the all the plot and
everything I can give it to every one of you
and tell you to go write it and you're all
going to come back with completely different
screenplays because you're going to come
with exactly who you are how you grew
up your tragedies your victories it you you
have the fingerprint and that's the beauty of
being a writer it's like people get so stuck on
ideas oh that's a good idea it's like it doesn't
the idea doesn't matter it's your fingerprint
on how the story how you're telling the story
because every story's been told they may pretend
like oh we got this new thing that we did it like
this and it's just like all right but in the end
it's still a heist movie or in the end it's still
a love story that you found a little different
angle on but they're the core of it the core
that we care about is still in there so that then
that will that'll never go away and that's when I
even say hey if you're lucky enough to get on an
Adam Sandler movie and Adam Sandler's rates Goofy
movies but if you're lucky enough to get a project
on that put your truth in there big go ahead and
be goofy but put an element of your truth in there
and that will make you stand above and they'll be
like I didn't when they read it they'll be like
what I don't know why I like this but I like it
and that's when we're putting our own truth into
the work and we don't have to totally spell it
out but that's when people go I connect to this
and I don't know exactly why or how but usually
that means the writer the writer has brought in
just utter truth and honesty and storytelling
we find people are sometimes
scared because you're so honest
it intimidates them because then that
means they have to meet you at that level
probably I should probably be less intimidating
well no not intentionally but but I mean this is
who you are and you want to yeah and I don't
expect I mean I don't expect everyone to have
to deal with the My Demons the way I deal with
them yeah there's it's I can tell when there's
avoidance in a Sci-Fi it's the alien isn't looking
at themselves yeah yeah the alien looks at himself
in the mirror and says I'm gorgeous and green yeah
there's there's just there's it's just interesting
because I think and I didn't even realize this but
I've read so much work that I can really tell fast
if they if they're into it and if they
you and if they had a stake in writing
it there's this with and I don't know exactly
what it is and I don't know how to explain it
but I could read five pages of something and
realize if they're invested and this is important
or if this is an exercise and they're trying
to and they're just trying to sell something
which could just be selling the teacher for a
good grade or yeah yeah okay or even scripts
that are given to me going hey can you can you
do a read through on this and give and give me
some pages of coverage and I'm like yeah and
I'll be like sometimes I've given back scripts
after 10 pages and I'll be like you didn't do
the work yet so and it's just and then they're
there's something I have with with writing
is I kind of can't I have a problem
sugar coating it sometimes but but storytelling
is my religion it's so it's nothing I will ever
if there are gods of Storytelling I'm
never going to go against the gods of
Storytelling so I hate it when someone asks
me oh did you like my book and I'm just like
I would never ask that of anybody I don't
even expect anyone to read anything I but
if someone says that I kind of have to either
tell them the truth or avoid it in some way and
and sometimes I might might say it was great to
see you on that publisher or I really like that
you got to work with that editor and all they hear
is great and like they don't hear that I didn't
say anything about the book but I have to kind of
I can't say a book's greater a screenplay is great
if I feel on my bones it's not and I might be
a jerk because of that I don't know also too
sometimes if you're going on a junket or press
junket you don't always have time to do I mean
you sometimes get this stuff last minute so you
don't always have time to read something or even
get a screener but but I mean sometimes it's not
just the work it's also the person that did the
work and that's fascinating too oh exactly oh I
totally agree I agree beyond belief there's I mean
that that the person behind the work intrigues
me I think I'm talking about my friends when
my friends come up to me and we'll ask that and
that throws me off but like when I interview like
every once every like 15 to 20 people will ask
and that's I kind of have to I have to restart
I have to re-steer it because I because
when I do interviews I'm there to have the
conversation with the person I'm not there to if
we discuss storytelling great if but I'd rather
I'd rather not go into the details of the
character of the book because that's for other
that's for their other shows I guess yeah or the
question I love how was it to work with so and
so there was such a big name is that's like one
of the I hear these journalists will ask that
in junkets and different things and sometimes it's
like well you're in the sense insulting the person
but hey that's just my my thing is I always
ask were they not were they were they nice to
work with Okay and it's really fun to hear because
and then I if I was yeah I was on a set and right
before covet and someone's telling me about one of
my favorite stars and I was like how how was he to
work with and they were like he was nice above
the line but below the line he was not a good
person to people and I was like ah that's that's
that I don't want to hear that yeah and plus you
don't know what the person is going through but
I get it I guess if you hear enough stories but
sometimes you don't there's a few people that
I've heard were difficult and then I've seen
someone come up and insist on a photo and
different things in a really rude way and
the person held it really well and I was like
wow they they actually so you sometimes you
just never know you need to know the audience
yeah that's telling you that if it's someone
that's been working in film for 20 years and
they're working on film after film after TV
show after TV show I'll take I'll take notice
when they but everyone knows everyone has a
bad day and sure sure I assume everyone has a bad
day so I never yeah if someone was like oh I'm at
someone on the street and he was a jerk I just
kind of look at him and go I yeah I don't care
I was watching an old interview with Jerry
Seinfeld I think it was with Charlie Rose and
he said something to the effect of he knew when
it was right to eventually leave the show and to
stop being a part of it and he said if I leave now
meaning stop the show the audience will have this
thing where they will never have to say it was
good and then it started to run out of gas how
does a writer know for their project or their
scene even that okay I think I should stop now
because if I keep going then they're going to be
like yeah this this kind of ran out of gas for me
yeah that's interesting I mean I call it keeping
everyone in the room as long as possible and I
know and and just because we're always trying to
avoid conflict as humans it's hard to sometimes
it's even harder to keep our characters
in scene when the conflict is just rocking
and let it let it play out and then so I think
what I think it's more important to let it play
out and then get them out to the next scene of
okay that happened and since that happened now
this is going to happen and how are they going to
get out of that situation so yeah I think that's
I feel like that's that's for scene work but if
I was Seinfeld I would have taken the money and
said what five million an episode let's go 10 more
seasons but I'm not but he's a stand-up comedian
he's not a he's not a at heart so like kind of
like like I get that I'm a novelist of the heart
so I'm not gonna I'm not gonna kill the novelist
in me to make a TV show work he's not gonna kill
the comedian and him to make a next season I guess
sure but in the reverse you you had a screenplay
that you were working on during this lockdown and
you wanted to extend it and do it in novel form
so there's been a reverse too where you realize
it sounds like you weren't done telling the story
and you wanted to tell more yeah I don't know
if it yeah I it just it doesn't feel finished
and I think it's it was just it's weird but it
was like speaking to me too much it just kept
speaking to me and I just I kept seeing it so
this is how it's showing itself to me I guess
which is very I really don't work in
the most efficient means I should have
Rewritten the screenplay and started pushing
it around and trying to make it happen but
that it's I don't know why I feel like I
had to re I have to kind of re-enter it
maybe because I that I was doing it as I thought
oh yeah this would be a fun story and it started
as a fun story then it meant something to me and I
guess when it meant when it means something to me
that's when it kind of like oh this actually I do
need to tell this this is this is something that
this is something that's personal to me that
I need to tell and that's when that's when
I feel like I'm only part of the process and
I have to I have to do justice to this thing
I have to step up and be the very best I can be to
what needs to be told with these characters and so
what what I'll in in heavy rewrites I'll really
know what needs to stay and What needs to go but
I I do know the story and I knew I know where
everything goes I just this is when I'm just
just for some odd reason I'm sinking deeper and
deeper and it who knows maybe it's maybe it's just
a book and never becomes a screenplay and that
just everyone laughs at me to the end and they
say well you're in development and I go I know
what that means I'm going to it's going nowhere
development hell that's what it means what's the
definition of that oh that's well the the oh your
your book's option oh my God oh my God who's
interested Antonio Banderas he's interested
oh my God and it's just like like four four four
there was a four people who called each other and
then Antonio Bandera said oh interesting and
then interesting became like he's interested
and he's interested became like he's clearing his
schedule and he's clearing his schedule became he
wants to talk to you but not yet so kind of like
a waiting for guffman type of thing okay right
yeah yeah and then it becomes a game of telephone
but you just don't believe anything you just you
just smile and say thank you yes and then it's
a miracle anything gets made so if someone's in
that situation what's your advice to them in the
situation of getting optioned yeah just enjoy it I
mean it's actually it's actually a nice ego boost
to have maybe someone talked about you it's like
it's nice in a good way yeah maybe it's an ego
boost like oh maybe someone read your book it's
just like oh that's sweet I don't it's not even
a relative that's nice so it's yeah I just I just
there's development hell but there's also just
that kind of a gratitude of well some people seem
to care a little bit and if it goes further great
and if it doesn't be working on someone something
else that's it's a story you need to tell so
yeah that's what I was wondering so especially
for someone that maybe is outside of the industry
they're in another state or country and their work
is being optioned so they're not waiting by the
phone like a like someone waiting for their date
to call who like alone on a Saturday night oh
Tommy's supposed to call and Tommy doesn't call
so what else should you be doing you should be
writing something new writing something new being
with being with your people and your writers and
your writer friends who can keep you in check it's
yeah I I've done everything wrong it's I
went to my 20-year High School reunion and I
that's before Confessions of a Teenage Jesus
Jerk was that's right when I finished my final
draft of Confessions of a Teenage Jesus Jerk
before I started submitting to agents and at
the reunion I was like I'm a novelist I'm a
novelist it's just like and I it was I was
the epitome of the stupid guy because I wasn't I
wrote a novel but no one may ever see the light
of the day fortunately I finally found an agent
and a publisher but it was sheer ignorance on my
part to say I'm a novelist before I have a book
published before I have an agent just because I
have a draft done and it could have been the oh
remember remember that guy Tony we went to high
school with we ran around the the the the everyone
telling you everyone he was a novelist I saw him
scooping ice cream the other day it's and not that
there's anything wrong with that because probably
most novelists need to do published all of us
need to do that anyway but I've just learned to
to to be a little more realistic
with myself and also like kind of
I guess I guess I had a lot of Joy at the time
and plus with that scenario being able to write
a novel after coming out of the Jehovah's
Witnesses and doing something that was so
utterly not not frown not just frowned upon to to
be creative and that's that was my whole kind of
life was just crushing my creativity so to be
able it was almost like I come out and go I'm
a creative person so yeah I was Johnny swade
I was that was that was kind of the buffoon
and I'm I'm gonna write a book on like one of
these days I'll write a book or an article on
everything I've done wrong in publishing in the
film industry so you don't have to it's just
it it'll be probably the largest book I've
written but you went to that that high school
reunion feeling good and you left feeling
good yeah no one tried to burst your bubble
no that's good well and I also found out that
they all knew I was a Jehovah's Witness I was
trying to hide it at school I'd be like I said
I would I would wear suits to school and like
I found out that this yeah I found the specials
record the first specials record and they were
mod and they all wore suits and I'm like I just
got to look like that so if I'm looking like
that at school and then I'm walking around with my
Bibles and watch Towers on Saturdays maybe they'll
just think I'm just walking around so I didn't I
thought I was kind of fooling everyone at school
but it turned out they were like oh no
we knew you're a Jehovah's Witness but we
always thought you were cool and I was like hmm
there's a lot of Revelations to me that night
interesting and do you still keep in touch
with any of those people I do yeah yes yeah
yeah okay and so now they see that not only
did you publish your book but then you also
made the film maybe they probably don't even
care right they get to see that they're I get
photos of their grandkids oh no or I'll find
out one one is a doctor and I mean he talked to
me about vaccination stuff and what is going
on there and it's just like yeah in the end
they might not be readers and they might not
be viewers and that's that's the beauty of it
it doesn't matter I always come into it now with
going I now I'm just like I assume no one's read
anything or seen anything I've ever done and if
they have then I'm pleasantly surprised and I say
thank you that's oh it's people will apologize oh
my God I haven't watched your film yet I'm like
you don't have to don't worry about it there's
other things in life going on there's so
and it's on IMDb you can you can watch
it it's like I on Amazon IMDb they have a
yeah yeah it's on Amazon it's on Prime and yeah
I don't know I haven't I think it's like someone
said it was on YouTube for free so I guess
the distributor put it on there for free which
I have no I have no what do you call it I have
no Authority on that on that end of it I just so
yeah it's out there people can watch it sure yeah
and there's the DVD too I I have the DVD I haven't
even opened the wrapper yet it's just like oh okay
it's yeah it's like the bottle of champagne you
just want to put you don't want to you want to
open it to I don't even know where it's at in my
house I was when when the Giants went to the World
Series and Tim in like 2010 and 10 minutes to come
got like three Cy Young Awards and they asked him
where he put him and he said he thinks they're in
the they he thinks that they're in his car and I
thought that was just so like dumb at the time and
then now it's like Oh no I got that yeah it's
because it's about the work it's not about the
it's not about the end it's
about the it's about the middle
would you say filmmakers today are more concerned
with forcing a message than telling a good story
I see it yeah I see it a lot and I
think I think people are concerned about
how they're portrayed instead of
the what the story is talking about
and which is the people do what they
need to do that's not how I work
I have no problem eating crow if I have to as
long as I'm telling the story is it's truthfully
and from the heart as possible but yeah I mean I I
see it a lot where people are people are trying to
steer their stories in a marketing way it's like
oh this is fresh and they're like well I'm writing
fresh and I said never ever do that because it
just it reeks of and authenticity but what there's
80 percent in in authentic films out there that
are making a ton of money so I'm not right on that
it's like very successful careers are being
made it's just not how I do it so it's
not how I approach it and it's not
how I want to consume it I don't want
I know I preached door to door knocking on doors
with the word of Jehovah for 20 years of my life
the last thing I ever want to do is preach even
if I believe in something I don't want my belief
system to to find its way into the story and push
it on the viewer I always want the viewer or the
reader to have their own questions and come
up with and go oh that's interesting I'm not
sure if that blank I'm not sure if blank I don't
want them to know the most beautiful compliment I
got when Confessions of a Teenage Confessions
of a Teenage Jesus Jerk came out the film was
they people thought I was still the Jehovah's
Witness and I was just like yeah I did it right
because yeah I do not believe in that belief
system at all it's very corrupt and it's
not good but what I'm telling the story my
message can't be in there I could tell I
could tell the world of but I love it that
people aren't sure if I'm still affiliated
with the religion or not that's the greatest
compliment and I feel like that should be
I would love that to be across the board
where if someone I don't want to know their
political affiliation I don't want to know I
don't want the film or the story to tell me
where they are I want I want them to explore the
Human Condition because that's what we all got so
he said something to the effect of 80 percent of
movies nowadays do seem to fall into a category
of a message they're doing quite well who
do you think the audience is for those films
um I mean it's interesting because I don't
think the audience this is why Hollywood
is a weird business because I don't think
the audience is too critical of certain
things because the general audience is there
just to be entertained what are we doing on
Saturday night honey we're going to the cinema
Cineplex well who's what's there I don't know
but that cute guy in that films in this film
well great let's go and they go and then they
enjoy it and then they go home they're they're
and their enjoyment of it is great well great
it's that's that's what it's for what even
if it has a message what a great gift that
those filmmakers gave to those people who got
to go on a date and then got to go home and
cuddle and just come together because they saw a
movie that I wouldn't necessarily care to see so
the viewership is just so vast that I I don't
want him to make a judgment on those people
I just I'm just I and those people do not want to
see my movie I mean and they've been vocal about
it on the internet so it's just like I turned that
off after five minutes because what this this and
this and I'm like yeah it's not for you that's
fine I because I don't write for everybody I never
want to write for everybody I want the I want
people to not like me and I'll feel like I'm doing
a I want people to like me of course but I do want
a certain population to not like what I'm doing
because then it then I know I'm then I know I'm
hitting the authenticity and I'm hitting the truth
and there's and and sometimes I disgust myself
I was I'm just like it's probably it's probably
why I can't read my old work or watch old stuff
is it's just too much because it's just too much
not that it's bad not that I don't not
that I don't think it's good it's just
it's too much to consume on my own as like
a reader or a writer or as a viewer it's
it's weird yeah like familiarity breeds contempt
so you're you're too much of yourself how we all
see ourselves in a different light not not
contempt I think it's just that was a point
in time and and that's and that's all that
and that's what it was and how lucky am I but
I'd rather watch a new episode of money Heist on
Netflix it's yeah I don't know I don't even know
why I said that I have therapy at 10 A.M tomorrow
I can talk to my therapist about it okay no I mean
I get it I mean some people after a while they're
like okay I'm glad I've passed this phase I don't
want to live here anymore in this like mindset
so I can understand that yeah it's yeah yeah
with so many remakes and reboots being made today
how can creators truly tell Original Stories
well yeah I don't I get the franchise thing oh
Aquaman worked and people know what Aquaman is
a Whopper Works they're gonna go buy a
Whopper instead of the hamburger at the
local mom pod joint because they don't
know what that is I think I don't think
there's a lot of originality in the stories
there's originality in how they're told and
the originality of how we're bringing our unique
voice and to what a story that's already been told
over and over again and then we get and then we
get together with the actors who have their own
unique ways of working and then the directors
have their unique ways of working and that's
where the beauty comes or that's where it totally
flops and dies but yeah I mean for the reboots
they got to make reboots so they can give money to
the stuff that maybe someone cares about I guess
and actors even got to do it too I don't
think any of these actors that work in
superhero movies I don't think they really want
to but that paycheck's really good and it's just
like I'm gonna get and that cost him again and
it's and I would get in the costume too because
who wouldn't want to buy a house in Los Feliz
sure the Palisades all right private schools
and yeah exactly it's great decision making so
yeah I don't think I'm getting hired on any of
those as a writer but me maybe maybe they want
someone contrarian to come in so sure have you
seen any remakes that were actually better
than the originals well Ocean's 11 for sure
way better than the train wreck that was the
Frank Sinatra doing a rat pack Ocean's Eleven
let me try to think of summer rates some remakes
that were better than the originals I don't know
it does happen sometimes I think it's a it's a
there's a there's a narrative where they try to
take great films from the past and remake them now
I think they should go for the crappy films in the
past and remake them I would love to see remakes
of terrible films like what I don't know maybe a
hard R version a Parent Trap no I don't know why
was Oceans 11 why was the first one so horrible
I well I've only seen it once I don't know
if have you seen it not not the you said the
one with Frank Sinatra yeah yeah yeah the
rap packs are yeah it's they didn't care I
don't think there was any care taken in it it's
like we got these Stars let's put them together
when it got to sodenberg seems like there was
caretaken and you can tell there's where there's
it's a blockbuster film but you look at the
frame by frame and you and you look at the
decisions that were made and it's just like every
decision is a great decision this is it's the
the and there's a lot of little elements in there
too I can't remember who wrote the screenplay but
the the beautiful little elements and little
choices that are made that's it's it's it's what
just brings it all together yeah
what classic film it would be a
travesty they tried to remake it today it
would just be insulting oh I don't know
I don't know I think everything should be given a
try I mean the Gus fans Aunt did a try on psycho
which was just awful it's like Vince Vaughn was
yeah I know it's no one remembers it there's a
reason it's because it was terrible and I think
they use the exact same script and it was yeah but
give it a try why not I mean hey people
it's if someone's gonna hey I'll write
a remake of something I'll I'll
write a remake of a great movie
and hope I can do better and then everyone can
just dirt on it and I yeah it's I say have fun
with it I say I say ruin great films why ruin
them well I mean if you're gonna remake them
yes it's it's a canvas it's like it's a why
why not go ahead and try to resketch it and
and I hate this word intellectual property but
it's all about oh we have this property let's
renew this property and let's make money on it
and I understand the business sense of it so
not that I'm gonna run out and be excited that
they remake A a certain film like The Bicycle
Thief or whatever is I was like let's remake it
modern day Los Angeles what go ahead actually
it's yeah it's there's so there's so much crap
being made it doesn't matter if more crap's made
I guess I'm okay yeah what if I take music though
which I know is near and dear to your heart as
well some some like you said was it on camera or
off camera the Public Image Limited was one of
your first concerts that you went to okay so PIL
[Public Image Limited] what if there was a band
that was trying to remake all those songs and
there was a Johnny Rotten that was the new the
new guy it wasn't Johnny Rotten but it was like
this new influencer guy they kind of looked like
Johnny Rotten and had sort of the same Sensibility
Justin Timberlake can remake it I'll be like oh
let's see if it's good okay yeah I guess I guess
I'm not nostalgic about it I've already had my
experience with the the either the original
film or seeing the original band and yeah so
I don't I'm I'm realizing now that I'm not
really nostalgic if somebody tries to remake
something I'm like go ahead and do it they
can remake Confessions of a Teenage Jesus
Jerk and make it a make it a superhero film
and but just send me the check okay why do
you think people though are so precious about
some of these films or adaptations of certain
books well like why are why are some people
so adamant that it shouldn't be done that it
because they're all fans that would that
are that are angry that the original work
yeah I guess they attribute meaning to
it and meaning to it in their own lives
but it's I don't know if they if they work
in film or if they are writers they could be
and and the writing and film is it's meant
to be critiqued it's meant to be just ripped
apart that's what everyone's supposed to do
that's the that's the beauty of of all of it
it's you're having a conversation about it great
it's it create it's continuing the conversation so
yeah I mean it's who there was like what was that
rock and rock and roll High School The Ramones
were in rock and roll high school then they had
rock and roll High School too Corey Feldman was
the it was the band of rock and roll High School
too and people hate it but I get a kick out of
it I'm like there's Corey Feldman pretending
like he's Michael Jackson it's just like it
I'm not upset about it because there's the
first one that meant a lot to me as a kid
and the second one is Corey Feldman
pretending like he's Michael Jackson
sure and the Ramones were at the height of their
stardom when that came out I I think they gained
more stardom I think after that movie came out
I think that's yeah I think they I don't think
they realized that was going to put them to
a new level but I don't know I can't remember
because I can't remember exactly when the
movie came out why I saw it on VHS oh nice.